So, do I sound different today?
Oh, I might have to up it up a bit.
Like, okay.
Okay, so this is going to be a surprise to, um, it is going
to be a surprise to my manager.
Because I didn't tell him what was going on.
It's going to be a surprise for everyone.
I couldn't technically I couldn't make it back home because
I didn't realize I might have fucked up my scheduling and
everything oh um um so I might have instead flown somewhere
closer and be like Can I borrow your setup for this one or
two days?
Depending if I could catch a flight tonight.
My badger's like, are you sure?
You're going to make it back in time for the sponsor here?
And I was like, I am so sure.
And my solution was to use someone else's setup that was
closer to Miami.
That,
that, that was my plan.
I was like, there's no way I could fly back to the West
Coast in time.
I,
he does not, he was like, you're home right now, right?
And I was like, don't worry, he's asleep right now.
He was like, you're home right now, right?
And I was like, yeah, I'm home.
Not technically my home.
But I'm at a home.
I'm...
I'm at a home.
So technically I'm home.
I am used...
I just...
So thank God.
Because, okay.
Okay.
How bad is my mic sound people?
I told my audio people.
I was just like, hey, I'm going to need some help real bad.
Oh, my pinky.
little bit okay let me turn it down okay okay the worst part
is that this person does not have a go XLR too so I'm like
god fucking I don't know I can hear everything I don't know
I'm not comfortable at all I was gonna be like maybe I'll
just cuz I have like today it's low this is okay there's no
okay okay maybe if I talk a little closer I am I am not I'm
in a...
It's a microphone.
It shouldn't be that bad.
Oh, you're quiet?
Oh, it's game volume high?
Okay, let me...
Alright, today's technical difficulty.
Let's...
Okay, I might actually...
I trust...
I trust this is my friend.
They're like, don't worry, it'll be fine.
They're like, don't worry.
I have a good setup.
I...
it's because like if i turn my face i have to oh i'm fuck
this pop filter this is fuck it all right pop filter off pop
filter is now off you're gonna hear every pop now um okay
all right i'm gonna lower the game volume i'm guys i swear
to god i'm trying so hard right now i
every single pop now um it's getting better yeah because now
the pop builder is not in my fucking face now um it's that's
not an idea i it's i trusted this person's setup but i get
it sometimes you should stop trusting oh shit wait i know
what was wrong okay my bad okay is this okay wait wait let
me okay wait oh my god i don't know what i'm doing i don't
know what i'm doing
oh oh oh okay okay how about now they had it why did it okay
they had their microphone at a hundred they had like at 50 i
don't know why okay all right so no they're they had their
microphone at 50% for some reason.
All right.
There we go.
Okay.
Is it a lot better now?
Guys, is it a lot.
Okay.
It's a lot better.
Yeah.
They had it at 50.
I don't, I don't know why.
Is it much better?
Thank God.
Okay.
All right.
How's the volume in everything?
Am I, am I, uh, it could be louder.
Okay.
Is my, uh, uh, can I get it?
It needs more.
Can we have, sound people did not want me to have this is
guys I might have to fly back I I don't know there's flights
today but right after the rivals turn I might have to fly
back after the rivals turn I think I thank you I thought I
you know okay I thought we could make this work I thought
we,
oh shit, okay, all right, okay, so my manager was actually
not sleeping and he was like, liar, I just didn't want you
to worry, I didn't want you to worry, you were like, I don't
know what you can do, and I was like, I wanted him to
believe in me, you know, I was like, I can confess this on
stream, because I knew he was gonna, I thought he was gonna
be asleep because he literally messaged me and was like i'm
gonna head to bed now um but the other staff would be there
ready to help you during your sponsor and i was like cool
who snitched who told him he you're right he also lied how
dare he lie to me all right okay i need to use a game filter
well it's at 0.0 decibels right now so I don't know what
else I could do is there a gain oh I can add my I can add a
gain filter all right all right sound guy I'm gonna add a
gain filter so everyone lied so it's not just me my entire
staff team lied so up i just didn't want him to worry you
know i didn't want him to worry because i knew if i try to
fly back in time um back home home um i wouldn't make it i
did i barely even made it in scrims today because i fucked
up i forgot time zones i forgot my phone was on east coast
time i was like they're like can we do this time like i
cannot do this time it has to be earlier was in the pst time
but um but like the they were doing at you know in discord
when they do at time and then at time the and it sets it to
your time zone you're like can you do this time at time and
i looked at it and i was like that's 5 p.m pst i can't do 5
p.m pst because i have a sponsor at that time and then i
didn't i forgot that my phone is on east coast because i'm
on the i was on the East Coast, you know.
I was like, oh yeah.
And then when I got back, when I like landed, I got a text
from the team, from the wireless team, being like, hey, we
have scrims in an hour.
And I was like, what the fuck do you mean in an hour?
Like, I literally, I'm in a car right now driving to like a
home.
I'm driving to a home right now What do you I thought I had
like five plus hours What do you mean I thought I had I
thought five plus hours to get ready What do you mean our
scrims is in an hour Anyway I fucked up there So yeah in an
Uber Um so this is past Doki's fault had a plan it doesn't
mean a great plan but there was a plan i was very stressed
out setting all this up by the way i i i was so stressed out
trying to i was just i i just i just do not feel comfortable
i was like i'm gonna it's gonna be okay it's gonna be okay
and i forgot how uncomfortable i am when i'm not on my
actual setup i
I forgot how fucking uncomfortable that look my plan was
that I was like I want okay so my deal with my manager by
the way my manager was like do not do this make do not go to
the Bahamas like you're not going to make it back in time so
my plan was that if I traveled back home yes I wouldn't make
it back in time but that doesn't mean like I couldn't be at
a home that would let me be back in time
because they're like you won't be able to do the sponsor if
you do this cruise and I was like don't worry I'll be able
to stream on that day
I was like do not worry I will be at home to stream this I
did not specify which home
All right, all right, all right, all right, all right, all
right, I'm adding a gain filter We will fix this, we're
going to slowly fix this All right, I have added a gain
filter, is this enough?
I did not, exactly, I didn't say my home
I did not say very quiet.
I'm so sorry, guys.
That's what it's for.
That's what today's stream for.
This is what today's stream for.
This is why we're on Twitch today.
This is why we're on Twitch today, guys.
This is the Twitch experience.
We're going in raw.
Raw unfiltered dokeybird.
Don't worry.
Oh, that's a lot.
That was red.
I saw.
Oh.
That's.
That.
I saw my OBS go red.
Okay.
Sound guys.
How's it going so far?
How you feeling sound yet?
How you feeling?
Okay.
So there's no go XLR.
But like they have their own thing.
I don't know, no, it's called Scarlet Something.
I don't know how to use it, guys.
I don't know how to use this mixer.
Everything is, like, connected to one thing, and I'm not
happy about it.
I can't lower my gain volume.
I can't lower my Chrome volume.
I can't lower anything.
I'm not happy.
I'm so sad.
I don't know what I'm doing I I don't know I just I just I
need babies go XLR I need babies go XLR right now I don't
know what I'm doing it truly is the sloppiest like maybe
okay wait maybe I can fly back after this I don't know there
is potential that I maybe I can just fly back after this
stream but then the thing is I do have a tournament at 9 a
.m.
that's what that's what's like holding everything back I
can't fly straight back home because I have a tournament at
9 in the morning you got it guys guys I thought it was pop
look I had plan.
I had a plan, guys.
I had a plan.
No, it hasn't failed yet.
It is salvageable.
We can figure this out.
We got the council, the sound council.
The sound council is on its way.
All right.
all right all right all right sound guys what's the plan
okay this is where it's at currently i will snip this and
send oops oops that's my water bottle all right okay we can
fix this we can fix this we can fix this we can fix this
guys i was so tired literally I got to the home not my home
if I got to a home I went I like booked it straight to the
PC because I didn't need a stream yet turn the PC on
downloaded Marvel Rivals I forgot to tell them the
downloaded Marvel Rivals I do got downloaded Marvel Rivals
they're like getting ready this ready to scrim and i was
like all right guys i'm ready i'm so ready to scrim right
now legit made it just in time for this i think i did pretty
well in the scrim yes i think i think i did pretty decent uh
i was so ready and then i had to spend that entire hour post
because i couldn't stay up anything obviously because i was
i was scrimming And then, and after Scrum, I have to set up
everything.
I have to make sure I got everything ready.
Don't worry.
Okay, all right, sound guys.
How's this now?
How am I sounding?
Like, how am I sounding?
Like, I need to, I need to know.
I'm going to mute this.
Well, you guys won't hear it.
I have to hear this.
I'm going to listen to myself.
I need to know how bad this could be.
It can't be that bad.
I'm gonna listen to myself
Hello jokie bird of the past It was not that bad It's not
that bad
It's just because I speak so loud That it's like echoing
Like that's just It's our it's not that bad You made it
sound so it's a peeking whoops sorry if I if I whoops oops
look we're salvaging this um oh guys but sound guys we're
we're sort of peeking so how do we fix that you can hear me
breathe I
it's the unique experience right now
we're okay girl all right it's the it's the unique not at a
home experience I'm at a home um interface gain down oh like
the the what the scarlet thing I when I do the scarlet I
push it okay turn down and then up the okay turn this down
okay i turned the scarlet down and then i'll do this and
i'll put it at 9.5 look see this is the best part okay i
need to make sure i said like five equals mute all right
while we're doing this let me look at flights let me look at
flights as a last resort I will look at flights while they
figure this out
I will get back in time wait actually wait I don't think I
can't wait a minute actually I actually don't even know okay
let me double check I actually don't know there might be a
chance that I will not get back in time okay um all right
let's see all right let's see one way I didn't buy a ticket
either I did not know how this was gonna go oh yeah guys
yeah it's oh oh yeah no yeah no there's yeah no there's no
way to fly today maybe tomorrow tomorrow.
Oh no.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Potential.
There's potential.
Maybe not very ideal, but potential.
There's, yeah.
Like, okay.
So, so I plan didn't go as far.
as staying for three days to stream the sponsor and then a
day after a rival's tournament and then a day after that an
apex tournament.
So like there wasn't really a plan other, like I put all my
hope in the setup.
I made a, I might have made a mistake.
I, I, I,
my entire plan relied on this setup working out
it could still work out guys guys guys we can still fix this
we can still fix this okay okay so let's do it 13 all right
13 don't worry i think by the time i don't even know we're
gonna be able to play power at this point it's just
salvaging this until we make it to the sponsor that's our
plan now our plan is to salvage this until we make it to the
sponsor it's okay sponsor doesn't start anyway make sure to
download that soon a miku colorful before the sponsor you
want to join in uh if you want to i have powworld installed
i did install powworld make sure i mean you can it's
literally you could you could hear in the background a
little bit um so make sure you download it before the
sponsor portion so you can join in on the game as well um
all right how much more we play okay turn it back up just
slightly under where you had it I just turned the scarlet a
bit up sound guys I I turned it a bit up so yeah for those
who didn't know I was gone on a cruise slash vacation in the
Bahamas um did nothing by the way my manager was very
stressed out did because at first there was no plan it was
more so of like me just checking out for a week and then but
then I saw a video of And I was like, I messaged silent.
And I was like, I want to take a cruise.
I've never done a cruise before.
It looks so cool.
And I basically have a couple of days off now.
And it's my one time to do it.
I haven't been in the ocean for years.
And he was like, don't do it.
You have a sponsor and two tournaments when you get back
exactly.
And then I was like, and I didn't reply back for it.
30 to minutes to an hour and then I was like sorry I bought
the tickets while you were talking
I bought the ticket while you were telling me not to do it
so it's a bit too late now and then my manager was like was
like did you at least get a dog sitter and I was like oh
yeah no dad's been gone three days already I I was like oh
yeah no dad's been at the dog sit there for three days now
because I when I say I was gonna start a vacation I did not
want a dog to wake me up in the morning I was just like so I
was like this is perfect like
is perfect he's already at the dog sitter i don't have to do
anything about that i don't have to worry about getting a
dog sitter uh all right let's see there are three up to 16
on the opiates okay three up on the 16 16 and then dollahair
but then okay all right how's this now sound guy sound team
sound team are we good I turned it slightly down on the dial
are we good now hello I'm when I start screaming it's gonna
be bad what's gonna happen guys what's gonna happen when he
when I start screaming how bad is it gonna be how how bad is
that gonna be when I start yelling and screaming
Do it now so we know.
Oh, I'm starting now.
Ah!
You have to be in the moment when I start screaming.
You know, I'll be like, ah, I have to be in the moment.
I can't just, like, scream randomly.
I will.
It's not an in-the-moment thing, I will have to admit.
I have to actually be there.
all right all right i'm waiting all right sound team sound
team what's up what's what else are we gonna do now they're
saying it's it's sound they're saying it's getting better
there's hope wait okay like i said i can't yell on i can't i
have that's an in the moment thing i can't like just let it
rip you know i had there has to be like in the moment
So I'll tell most of the story on YouTube or when I'm back
on my actual setup.
But like, anyway, so I was on a cruise flight.
I had to, by the way, I also had to buy a, buy like a
swimsuit too, or two swimsuits.
Because I haven't touched the ocean, like the actual ocean
ocean, like the water ocean.
Because I was always like really afraid, not afraid, but
like I was like not really a fan of the ocean for a while.
It was like 10 plus years.
I haven't really actually touched the ocean, ocean.
So I had to buy like a swimsuit and stuff like that.
Very cute swimsuit.
I was really happy with it because it was like, it was
really cute.
I won't describe more than that.
Let your imagination run wild.
But it was really nice.
So I had to like buy, like I had to, that's why I was like,
I have to do last minute shopping, guys.
I have to do last minute shopping.
a little more in the OBS all right I'm sending it to 17
decibels 17 17 it's on 17 now um so I am not getting okay
funny thing you know because like I thought like the fancy
dining halls you need because it says there's a dress code
so I was just like oh shit well maybe I'll just buy the
shoes um at the cruise you know and then legit I like went
to the I was like I'm gonna go on the last day because like
I don't know you guys know this but on the cruise Everyone
just usually gets like go to the buffet area because that's
like what's most known for But then I was like you know on
the last day also also I gambled guys I lost like a hundred
dollars But like I had a good time I lost like 150 dollars,
but like I had a good time.
I can see why it's I I I can I can see it I I $100 on slots
I it was gone it's danger it's there I was like I'm having
so much fun I I see it I see it but luckily luckily I really
wanted to go to adult karaoke because I didn't get chance to
sing but it was so fun seeing all these drunk people on the
last I went last day to a last day at the casino but it was
really fun seeing like all these guys like all these people
just drunk karaokeing so i had to see it it was like the
last 15 minutes and i i was so tempted i was so tempted to
it's no i can see it though i can see why i it gambling is
is oh i i can see it i it's dangerous i the thing is the
thing is one of my friends was like how are you enjoying
this you're like your role it's happened so fast i think i
was in the slots for like 10 minutes and it was god it was
god a hundred dollars just like that i i couldn't believe it
i because it just happened so fast it don't guys and then i
played blackjack too because like i was like it's like the
video games you know I didn't play poker I was like talking
to like for those who didn't know I'd be um I was talking to
like the art like art gallery people like I was hanging out
with them and it was I was through I was talking about you
know like I was like oh yeah I want to play poke I was
tempted to play poker and because it and and then one of the
guys there like one I think was like I don't remember the
guy or girl uh like one like one of them was like poker so
hard though but I was like it's like the video games
it's just like the video games you know like the one with
the team fortress like with heavy in them and then they're
like yes because in video games they tell you if you have
two of a kind or two pairs or full house but you don't get
that in real life
they're like in real life you don't get two of a kind it
doesn't tell you if you have a two of a god or two pairs or
whatever ever you have to like know it but you just have to
know yeah you have to be able to know like exactly what you
have yeah no chat yeah exactly no chat to backseat me so i
was just like oh yeah that seems hard if i don't have my
little my my side chat over there and the side just be like
do this do that but it's like you mean you mean i don't have
the yellow outline of the cars that tell me that i have a
full house you mean that doesn't happen anyway so i played
um also i brought up the gain a little bit okay put a
limiter threshold all right i'm putting a limiter
a limiter uh limiter at zero zero point Alright, I did it.
There is a limit of 0.5 Sound team.
I did it.
Okay.
Anyway, so I played blackjack and like I went on a table
that was like Like minimum bid was like $25 just $1.10.
I saw there was like the The bougie rich people table where
the minimum bid was like Was like $2,000 or some shit and I
was like like bro like
no so I went on the peasants table with $25 buy in it was a
$10 buy at the high rule I was just like yeah no that's
2,000 for one game of black imagine like to your fucking
down payment for that for white that's too rich for me buddy
so I went to the 25 but then they were like you can only pay
50 and I was like what do you mean 25 is 25 like like 25
what the fuck do you mean fit like that why does it say 25
on the board anyway so i paid 50 instead of 25 there was a
10 table too but like i didn't realize the thing is when i
saw those tables i didn't realize it was numbered like it
was a buy-ins were different i just thought oh all tables
are 25 uh i just thought well all tables just happened to be
25 and i walked around afterwards i was like what are
there's a 10 buy-in what the fuck you mean there are other
the numbers are different the numbers change wild concept i
know fucking wild concept
anyway I like won my first two games I won the first two
games of blackjack and then it got to I got like $100 and I
was like oh my god I'm letting it ride oh I'm feeling it now
I'm feeling blackjack and then I was like hit me and I was
you know what instead of going one like you know I was
betting $25 chips per $25 chips.
And I got to $100.
I got two in a row.
And I was like, whoa, whoa.
Oh, I'm feeling wild now.
I was like, you know what?
I'm going to let it ride.
I'm going to put two chips in.
Oh, two old chips instead of one.
Oh, I'm fucking going wild.
Two old chips.
Oh, and I lost.
And I was like, you know what?
Maybe that was just a flute.
Let me put two more chips in.
It'll be different this time.
And I won.
And I was back to $100, baby.
I'm letting this shit ride.
And I was like, you know, I'm going to, there's no way I
could lose again.
And then I put two more chips again.
Yeah.
You don't end on a loss.
And you don't stop on a win streak.
And then I lost.
And I was like, there's no way I'll lose two chips.
times in a row because I broke the pattern last time and I
lost it all and then goodbye hundred dollars and then and
goodbye hundred goodbye there's no I was like I can't lose
two times in a row that's impossible it didn't happen before
so so that's my first by the way i've never been in the
casino before by the way i'm not they're very guys they're
very they do not do not follow my example it was because
it's my first time at a casino so i wanted to like have the
pure experience i i was so confused by the way i did not
even know how to have fucking access because you're supposed
to use your car like use your like cruise card or whatever
to act to like pay for stuff i was just like it kept i
didn't in my cruise card which was like you know maybe the
first sign of the of life telling me not to do it and i had
to like i went up to the lady and was like how do i insert
money into my card because i want to do the slots machine
like they're like just tap the card i was just like oh but i
tapped it but it says i'm zero i don't know i think she's
just like what the fuck is around with you like how do you
not know what they're like oh yeah i put your pin i'm just
like oh what's the pin though i don't even i don't even know
that i just want to and papa smurf they give us super uh
they give the bitties they thank you i won't gamble again
goes all in on no it's apparently like a special pin for
your card like that i won't say it Because what if you had
attack my card?
Okay, let's see.
Let's bring the Scarlet Dial down again very slightly.
Okay, I brought it down slightly.
And we bring it up to one.
All right.
One more decibel, guys.
They believe.
See, sound team believes.
They're like, we are so close.
Don't say that.
Have confidence.
We will.
save this.
Look at that.
They're so confident.
They're, we,
we can do this.
Okay.
All right.
How, how's this now?
Sound team.
Don't keep it.
Okay.
How's this now?
The sound team, they're doing, they're doing their best,
guys.
Oh my god.
Oh, my manager might need it.
Okay.
All right Okay, my manager was like we gotta test this with
stuff Okay, sound team guys gotta be awake when stuffy joins
in and also the game guys we have to we have to fix this
sound There it's all no pressure or anything, but it's all
on you guys and I'll be very very angry I'm joking Have you
heard of the abuse goblin?
I'll be very very angry
no pressure but but but it's all it all relies on you guys
not not the goblin at the base of it all right let's see all
right sound team is there anything else anything else
anything else we have to do maybe we'll play more power
world after this but i don't know i don't know i feel bad uh
more we keep it here for the baseline oh after i say you
guys know about the abuse goblin you're gonna stop oh now it
seems okay oh at the face the microphone dead on that's a
little difficult i haven't done that a while facing the
microphone straight up for my streams it's been a while
since i've done that all right okay uh all right sound yeah
everything that sounds so much better all right okay this is
me it's not like fully facing it but is it okay sound guy
i'm not fully facing the microphone but is it still okay i
just need to know is that okay good on your end so much
better look at that see i told you i told you guys i told
you everything is salvageable see i'm gonna i'm gonna
message my staff my manager do you believe in me
i messaged them i was like do you believe in me also okay oh
yeah i forgot now it's time for the game sound now now all
right round to sound guy now we have the game I don't don't
feel like lots can still go wrong believe okay
all right so magic don't tell me it's don't tell me it's
blue the setup and i wrote back i won't say anything
ignorance is bliss
is bliss
you said don't tell you so I let you live in ignorance
He's like, okay, sound sus enough.
Okay, all right.
Yeah, but sound team.
Sound team.
How's pow world's volume?
How?
okay i'm sorry he said something that was a little mean and
i should not have laughed
okay all right let's time for power let's go oh shit i do i
forgot Something.
Alright, let's hope that...
Oh, fuck.
I'm gonna put a picture on.
Because I'm worried.
I'm just...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, let's see.
I forgot to...
Oh, fuck.
Okay, give me a sec.
I forgot to do, like, the screen.
I don't remember how this works.
Okay.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, this was so risky what I just did.
Let's go.
Battle world.
Okay.
All right.
Everything's fine.
Join multiplayer world.
I need to figure out where you find all the information.
I've up the PAL world.
I've up the PAL world volume.
Alright, let's see.
What's the PAL world password, though?
For the PALs.
Everybody's so ahead now.
I was gone for one plus week.
And then everything happened in one plus week.
And then enter password.
Uh...
Password.
There we go.
I'll save this.
Alright, I'm in.
Now we're palling.
Now.
Make another 50.
Oh, shit.
Oh, hey!
Hey!
Hello!
Hey, guys.
Okay, how did, oh my god, you guys are so, you're so juiced
up.
Yeah, check out my sword.
Oh my, you guys are still using baby swords?
What, this is not a baby sword?
This is an epic sword.
Excuse me, Lord.
Yeah, yeah, you guys are still in the Stone Age.
Now, you guys haven't industrialized yet.
We're in my pistols, my merit, like, what's it called, my
little shotgun.
I've already made like five of them.
Uh-huh.
Prove it.
Show me a gun.
I'll have to make another one, actually.
Where am I?
I'm right here.
Check out my guns.
You have a...
You can see them with your eyes.
Oh, yeah.
Your Civil War...
Your Civil War 1800 bayonet.
That takes three hours to reload.
of machinery I wonder how long this shotgun will take to
make it wait how long does it take to reload wait was this
your only gun man
making a shotgun I thought you had five guns where is it
yeah I gave them all away to other pals oh oh you you gave
the pals guns oh my god oh my god oh my god there's a little
dog we're working here what's that dog doing go yeah five
musk muskets five muskets yeah you're making a makeshift
shotgun oh my god yeah that's dangerous this is this is
literally how the the revolution happened with a shotgun
think our forefathers used a shotgun the industrial someone
has it has to be makeshift before it is perfected that's
true yeah this is the industrial revolution baby that
shotgun that shotgun looks like it's gonna blow up on
yourself stone all right oh my god are we going back to the
stone age wait doki have you been to the second base yet oh
we have a second base yeah let's show me No, this is why I
haven't logged in since our stream.
I literally came back from the Bahamas today.
I'm so sorry I made you edit the server.
Yeah, I was like, literally, I was in the Bahamas.
I just got a text message from you and be like, I can't
access the server.
Hey, this is what happens.
No, I actually was actually an escape room because there was
like an escape room activity and yeah I got out of the
escape room and I saw the SOS from Mimi and I was like oh
shit next time you can leave me on red no it's okay it was
like the last day it's all right you gotta pal it up what
was the what was the escape room theme it was It was on the
cruise, so it was, it was sort of pretty, you know, like
that makeshift shotgun, it was sort of like that.
Oh, no!
Wait, did you make it out?
It was, oh yeah, there were, okay, so there was, I was
talking about it in Mimi's chat room, but like, there were
some kids in there because there's like four children in
there because it was like, you know, summer vacation is
ending, so the parents were like, last week before you gotta
go back to school and then i felt so fucking stupid in that
escape room because it was like 90 math related questions or
whatever and yeah and i was like stuck on this math problem
where it's like one so the number at top is like 13 and you
have to use and there's like one numbers one to 15 i have to
use it one time and each box is like like it's like five
plus three minus 10 minus 5 equals 13 and then it breaks
down even more you got to fill up all the numbers I was on
that question for like 20 minutes or some shit I gave up and
then this like teenager this 15 year old kid took over my
question finished it in like five minutes and was like I
solved it and I was like okay and then there was this other
there's a seven year old kid who was like out of his phone
and was like chat GPT how do I yes and then like I'm speaker
so you could hear the phone trying to like answer like the
child it was it was it was the escape room we did not escape
we that's crazy i didn't even know they had escape rooms on
cruises on cruises that's yeah they did they did we have to
pay ten dollars yeah it was ten dollars you already paid for
the cruise i know okay i realized cruises love to suck money
off of you i i figured it was my very first cruise i i
realized you have to go to the places that says
complimentary I've never been on one either.
Oh, it's, it's, it's very fun.
Just make sure they don't get you.
They don't, they don't, they don't get you.
They'll suck you in.
Oh my God.
Okay, so I was talking to like one of the staff, cause I
like, I befriended some of the staff there on the cruise and
they were like, I was like talking to them about like, I
don't even know how we got to this topic, but, oh yeah, I
was like, what's the best cruises?
and they were saying like there's this specific cruise line
that's really really good but it's all like 50 plus year
olds because they're like you know they're they're retired
age you know so they have all this money to spend because
that particular cruise line is just all 50 plus year old
adults like grandpas and grandmas and i was like oh so like
grandpa so i was like oh so it's like it's like a swingers
cruise right
I was like oh so like you guys encounter a lot of swingers
on those crews you know because you know when you you know
that's sort of like the reputation and they're like telling
me um on there's actually a cruise line on a specific month
called like on November 7th called the bliss cruise where
it's where people are literally naked the entire yes yes
they're telling me i was like yes on november 7th there's a
specific cruise dedicated to swing you remember the day you
literally stuck with you i was like i was just like what
because they're like yes and then they're like they convert
all like it's literally like the like they were all just
naked and i was like and what and then they're like yeah so
like i would they would be like yeah so like in the auction
on an art gallery auction they're all just gonna be naked
they're sitting there and i'm like what like i was just i
was sitting there i think that has to be that's too specific
to fill a whole cruise ship of people who are interested in
nude art auctions how many people are into that they can
fill a whole cruise um it's called all of them that must be
yeah that must be all it's a specific I was just like, what?
Anyway, anyway, so I learned a lot about cruises that day.
That's crazy.
So don't sign up for any cruises on November, guys.
You might accidentally get on that specific.
November 7th, avoid any cruises on November 7th.
Wait, what was the date again?
So I, what was the date again?
I gotta avoid it.
November 7th, 3.7?
all cruises on on November 7th bliss cruise avoid that make
sure you're not there I'm just making up the web page oh
yeah bliss cruise calm everybody adults only wait you look
at the website adults only clothing optional cruises for
adventurous couples that crave freedom connection and
unforgettable experiences and things.
Clothing optional.
When they like go to port and they watch everybody from the
cruise school.
Like imagine you're just enjoying your vacation on the beach
at a cruise school with naked people.
Naked old people.
Save though on laundry.
You just need two outfits there and back.
I was like, thank God clothing is optional.
this one is the wonderland cruise that's november oh you got
the day wrong don't you always went on the wrong road wait
wait what do you mean go on the wrong way what do you mean
go on the wrong oh i'm sorry i'm two days off y'all i'm
sorry that you booked a ticket for the november 7th cruise
what am i going on
what are you tickets for whatever it is can't be worse than
the no it was great though like i really i forgot okay so i
haven't been on a beach in a long time so i haven't put on
like forgot how to put on sunscreen and oh yeah i saw your
tweets about getting yeah i got i put all the sunscreen in
the front because I was just like yeah the sun's gonna hit
the front I forgot the sun can 360 you like I forgot it's
regular and then your back is all red yes it's all red
because I forgot the sun can 360 I didn't realize it's all
over I thought as long as it's see I see the sun and the sun
If I don't look at it, the sun can't hit me, you know?
So I fell asleep in the ocean, like, You fell asleep!
Yeah, the worst you could do!
Yeah, with my back against the sun on the little floaty
floating out in the ocean.
Oh my god.
Yeah, and so it wasn't...
Also, why do we have a shipping container?
What the fuck is in here?
I don't know.
Who put this shipping container?
here no one knows no one it just appeared randomly yeah this
one shows off my arms oh wait you look good check me out
you're good thanks whoa feel good what what the pals do you
have and show us our pals who's a little show so many pals
like you can show give us a show actually that reminds me i
want to get i want to start taking out this pal Yeah.
This guy's gonna be my new main.
He's my new main.
Whoa, your new main?
Yeah, he's so cute.
Which one do I want?
Maybe the runner?
We're up the volume a little.
Apparently Mimi's a little quiet, so I got her up a little.
All right, sound team.
How is it now?
You can't adjust people individually, can you?
No, you can.
You have to...
You're also quiet for me.
Yeah, you're quiet for me too.
Nimmy is fine though I think Oh am I quiet for you Yeah you
are for me Alright alright let's see Yeah um so I'm also not
at home Oh No no okay so Because I have a sponsor today too
So but and my manager Was like don't do the cruise You're
not gonna get back in time And I was like don't worry I'll
be back at home But I didn't specify who's home I'll be at
so so I was like I flew the closest closest place I can do
go stream and and I was just like don't worry this setup
will work I'm still trying to fix the setup I so you chose
to play power world instead no no the no the spot this is my
test you know it's my stress test before the sponsor yeah
yeah I'm adjusting the volume and everything yeah Yeah, it's
pretty smart, I guess.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Trust the process.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Well.
Whoops, sorry.
Sorry.
I started shooting.
I started blasting.
Yeah.
I know I cranked up my own individual OBS.
It could just be, like, my, let's see, my end.
Somehow I feel like you're getting quieter.
I know, right?
looking at two it just turned it off and i was like oh
nimi's i'm gonna be too loud i'm reminded yeah it's normal
all right am i am i still too quiet you're still pretty
quiet how about man am i just quiet on your end yeah okay
wait i got i got an idea look at the way he walks i got wait
who's your new pal isn't that big ass llama no oh fluff bird
which one is your man look at look how cute he is oh that's
the whisp that's the whisp i got one of those two yeah me
too wait i got him yeah three of them yeah well i already
named mine i boo you can't you can't take that that one's
mine no mine's a meow cat meow cat
they're so cute yeah look at them they're like a squad the
name of the enemy in zootopia too wait what's oh yeah the
wait who named a paver that's neemie's paver yeah you know
how he was he's more popular than the the snake and this the
snake character in japan or some shit because he's like
voice acted by famous japanese say you oh he is yeah i
forgot who i remember like they create so much merch for him
in japan that's so i feel so bad every time i release him he
goes straight to work i know it's okay it's his job what is
this all right let me see how i can turn up myself up for
you guys i can save the genetic data of these what oh yeah
you can you can save your genetic data and then like power
them up if you have like a bunch of them are you gonna well
it's not really cloning it's more like it's more like oh
what's it called um where you try to breed the perfect uh
specimen oh yeah yeah yeah eugenics it's it's more eugenics
than cloning which is not great stop working meow cat you
don't need to work you're a luxury cat these are the house
cat?
Yeah, it's like.
Let's see.
I'm literally transferring across servers is what my chat's
like.
Oh, wait, is it a different thing?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
If you want to, I made an option so you can, if you want to
play in a different server.
I don't know why you would do that, but.
Who would do that?
yeah i don't know why you want to do that on our server yeah
but like you can transfer a pal to a different server and
take your pal there oh yeah yeah i'm gonna go farm a level
99 and then bring it over yeah bring it over let's see i'm
gonna go teleport i'm gonna go explore all right i'll see
you guys later yeah i'm gonna fix mic a bit.
Nimmy, did you want to go to the other base?
Oh wait, Doki, you want to come to the other base?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, I want to go to the other base.
Let me fix my stuff first.
Give me like five minutes.
My sound team's trying to help me right now.
They're like it's, they're having a party right now, having
a great time.
Let's see, input device.
Maybe this?
They are having a party.
They actually are having a party.
Wait, are they having a party?
Oh, how's my volume now?
Is it better?
No.
Okay, all right.
Apparently it's not better.
Give me a sec.
Doing my best, guys.
I'm like body blocked by your life.
Mama, right?
He's a little bit cute.
He's a little big.
This is the best I this is the only one I have sound team.
I don't have anything else
What do I do?
How do I make it loud if how do I make myself loud sound
team?
I'm ready to go to the other base Whoa.
Oh, they're, they're trying.
Wait, who are they attacking?
Oh my God, they're attacking that one lamb.
Why?
Who did you aggro if you try to kill someone?
Oh, this guy.
Oh, oh, oh.
They're obliterating this level one cat.
This poor cat, this poor fucking cat.
What's happening?
We got aggro.
All right, I'm, show me the other base.
okay it's pretty far though check the map all right we can
fast travel oh my god why is the mission we gotta explore we
gotta explore yeah actually i gotta pee real fast though oh
okay well while you're peeing i'm gonna do tech support my
tech guys were like we have a way they have a way but it's a
lot of steps all right sound team Tell me the way.
Good luck, good luck.
Tell me the way, sound team.
Am I still hungry?
Oh, I'm starving.
Okay, I ran out of food.
On your ground, I'm going to steal some food.
It's fine.
They don't need this.
Oh, now I'm a pouch.
Did I not make one?
Oh, shit.
I didn't make a pouch.
oh my god wait where's the food pouch i know i had like the
the shitty one where's the shitty food pouch
i do not have it oh no is that the shittiest they have is
that yeah i thought i had the small feet oh there it is yeah
i can make it
let's see oh do i already have it where is it am i blind oh
whatever i'll just make it just because i can all right um
where is it i thought i put it in my oh there it is there
you are no longer hung you
No longer hungry.
Sound team, what if I put my, what if I up my thing up
again?
Sound team, how bad would it?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I can swap microphones, but then we're going to do this all
over again.
Is it worth it?
I think it'll be worth it because the microphone might be
better.
Hello?
What happened?
Okay.
do have another microphone I think it's worth it why do I
hear Nimi everywhere oh it's a glitch so you might have to
like you might have to log out and log back in okay wait
where is she even I don't know I don't hear her so like oh I
don't hear so she must be far if you hear her she's you're
really quiet and she's so loud you have to log in and log
out okay I'll log out I'll log out Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the only way.
Oh, she's gone.
Oh, oh, Nimi logged out and logged back in too.
She might have had the bug as well.
Salatin, you want to do another balancing thing?
I have another microphone.
We have, we have 20 more minutes.
Hey, welcome back.
Hello.
Hey.
All right.
Take me to the new base.
I don't even know where I need one.
I'm going to teleport to the closest thing that I have,
though.
You probably don't have it.
The TP point.
Then I'll just fucking travel to the base.
Okay.
I'll see you there.
Yeah, I'll see you there.
Thank you.
All right.
No, right.
I guess maybe a stove.
Oh, it looks kind of weird.
Hey.
Oh, that's where you went.
I went to sneakily edit the base Yeah, Mint's gonna Yeah,
she wants to walk Yeah, she wants to walk And I was like, I
She's like, I'm gonna TP to the closest Oh, that's so cute
Oh my god, this is This is better than my real apartment
Thank you, thank you Wait, this house is Oh my, we're living
the life Three stories Oh my god.
Why are pals depressed?
No, don't worry about the pals.
Oh, okay.
Wait, why is this one passed out?
Is he dead?
Is he...
I can sort of tell.
What would...
How did you guys pick?
Did you pick the location?
I...
I didn't pick the location.
Wait, who picked this place?
I think Matara picked it.
It was built on a 45 degree angle, so whenever you try to
place anything, it's really difficult.
And there are a billion high level pals that come and attack
the base and try to light it on fire every once in a while.
No, it's not too, not that bad.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, why are some pals so hungry?
What's going on?
The base needs some help.
But at least it's beautiful, right?
Yeah, I guess.
It's like, you know, the sacrifices you have to make, you
know?
Exactly.
Yeah, sometimes you gotta starve some pals to make money.
Wait, they shouldn't be too hungry.
I don't know.
guys hungry oh matara built it and then he's right here
though matara built it and abandoned it oh shit you like
it's like you're it's like flipping homes you found that
you're about to flip it that's true i did come and just
built this here i did flip it
i don't know where oh my gosh she's so far min is so far She
walking.
Yeah, she's walking walking.
Yeah, I was gonna say how does she have no other checkpoints
near this base I still have I'm gonna I'm gonna teleport
over there.
All right, I don't have anything near.
I'm gonna oh shit.
Wait, oh my wait wait They're all depressed Yeah Extremely
unhealthy due to neglect Extreme But you didn't fix them.
It's really expensive.
Therapy, that's true.
That's true.
Therapy is pretty expensive.
Just get better, just get better, you know.
I mean, they have, you know, they could just take a walk
outside.
The sun will cure you.
Touching grass will help.
Yeah.
Is it because there's not enough, no, there are enough beds.
Why are they depressed?
everything they could want.
That's what I'm saying.
They have a bed.
They have a hot tub.
They have food.
What more do they want?
They're so good.
What's the word?
They're so spoiled.
Alright, let's go meet up with Mint.
Are you ready?
Okay.
It's this way.
I have a dog, do you have a, do you have a mouth?
Oh, wait, yes, yes.
All right, let's go.
You said you don't have a TP spot?
Yeah, yeah.
Well, Mint doesn't, so she's going to walk all the way.
Is it this way?
Okay.
Should we go meet her?
Yeah, it's like, oh my god, I'm so confused where it is.
Is she this way?
Is it this way?
I can't tell.
Oh, there, I'm going to go all the way.
way down here okay where yeah no fall damage thank god my
wolf has some tanky legs i know oh yeah there's a there's a
fast travel point here oh nice
okay okay min's like all the way there wait they didn't have
food or beds when you found them she built the house wait
you found them abandoned yeah
Oh My god, it was a bit of a sorry state It's like it's like
you found an abandoned orphanage There was a man there too.
There was a man who was mad was it?
Well, he's still there honestly.
Oh, yeah, yeah, I saw him there.
Yeah, he's also depressed Yeah, yeah Him I can I can
understand why Mint!
Wait, she's nearby.
Mint?
Mint!
Where are you?
Oh, is she over there?
It's Bowser!
Yeah, oh shit, there's Bowser!
Wait, you see this guy?
Yeah!
What are you doing?
Hey!
What are you doing to that guy?
Hit him.
I wasn't doing anything.
I was just passing by.
I'm going to the base.
You level 36.
I think we could take him.
I think we can.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Okay.
Go for it.
I'll watch him here.
You're the carry.
You're level 27.
You're literally the tank of our team.
I'm deep.
I'm range.
I'm the ranger.
You're the only one who's going to be able to catch him.
Yeah.
I have a hyper ball, actually.
You're literally the tank of the squad.
Oh, now.
Wait, where are you?
Why are you?
You're literally the dog.
What do you mean?
I'm right up here on this.
You're so stupid.
Oh, you're okay.
I thought you turned I got turned into cooler dad.
Yeah
Yeah, the cooler dad my dad.
Oh, they're blowing stuff up down there.
I don't want to I don't want to bother them Hit him.
No, I'm trying to get to the wait.
There's a there's a there's a cave right here I'm out of it.
Why are you scared?
Yeah, need me Don't worry, Demi, I got you!
I did one!
Oh, I'm not letting cooler dad die.
I'm not letting cooler.
No, he's not.
He's not.
He wanted to.
Don't worry.
I got the high ground.
My one damage.
I'm doing...
I'm doing one hit on his tail.
One damage.
You got this, Demi.
You're so healthy.
I'm tanking, I'm tanking.
You're tanking, you got this.
Oh!
Oh no!
She's sharp.
She's really sharp.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Wait, I think Min, I think our tank's gonna die.
I'm trapped!
I think our tank might die.
He knows Hyperbeam!
No, don't worry, I'm taking higher, higher ground.
I'm taking...
I think this is it for us.
Oh, he got friends, you!
I'll raise you I'll be a hero man distract him oh he's on me
he's looking at me mint mint aggro take the aggro take the
aggro I'm only level 11 take the aggro take the aggro take
the aggro take the aggro take the aggro take the aggro just
hit him mint no let me get let me get him no I get what do
you mean oh my god Oh my god, Timmy!
Just take it, take the aggro!
He's still aggro, Timmy!
He's still aggro!
12, 11!
Men go!
Men, frozen!
No, no, no, no!
No, no, no, you have more!
No!
We did it, guys.
And we bravely ran away.
Oh my gosh.
We bravely ran away.
What?
I'm crying.
It's okay, she's walking away, he's walking away.
What did you do?
Why did you look at him?
I did it, I did it.
Why did you try to come back?
It was only.
He hyper beamed on me.
You turned around.
We saw you turn around.
I did it.
You saw nothing.
You're a big fat liar We saw it.
Nimi and I saw you turn around.
What are these guys?
They're so, oh my gosh, they're so cute.
They are cute.
Oh shit, maybe I shouldn't.
I didn't realize.
I keep forgetting my level.
All right.
Oh my god.
There's so many of them.
oh whoops what's going on wait why are you frozen they
freeze you oh oh it's because i'm i'm tanking instead of
using a pal i just want them i just want them you just want
them for the sake of it there was a big one too there was a
just pop there was yeah there was his popa somewhere oh i
want i love the sweet they're so cute they might be in my
new Oh, you gotta see the big boy.
The big papa boy.
Big papa sweet.
Yeah, big papa sweet.
Wait, I'm gonna capture this one too.
Yeah.
Oh, you killed him.
Oh, you didn't.
Oh, he was like so close.
There's one more over here.
Yeah, I have a mercy ring.
Oh, that's smart.
Yeah.
There's one more over there.
Yeah, there's two more.
Gotta catch them all.
steel is coming in and taking my hey you gotta be faster
wait did we both get it i got it yeah yippee i leveled up oh
that's funny yes oh yeah the big guys call sweep sweep sweep
sweep yeah sweep sweep where is he i don't see him i don't
think he's here anymore i think he You killed all his kids
so he left We didn't kill them We enslaved their children I
wanna go to the new base I wanna go to the new base Have you
ever visited the new basement?
Huh?
Have you ever visited the new base?
No, I wanted to explore until there.
Well, I mean the house is great.
I heard other burying opinions.
Wait, on the house?
On the house?
Oh, on the house.
Oh, who did you hear?
Who did you hear it from about the varying opinions?
That means you said that.
Oh, I thought you meant to look this way.
Yeah, yeah.
The house I heard is great.
I don't know how we're gonna get up there.
What's here?
Parkour.
How did you before?
Jump down.
Oh, no, I don't, I think I never did.
I always just teleport.
Oh, you teleport.
Alright, it's right here.
I'll regain, regain.
Oh, there he is!
There he is!
Sweepa!
Yeah, there he is.
He's taking care of his children.
Wow!
He's huge!
Yeah!
He's got a mustache.
Oh, he's got a mustache!
Yeah, you gotta catch him!
Sweepa!
He's really cute.
I'm gonna do it.
Wait, I'm making a null.
Wait, I'm making a null of sweet...
Wait, actually, why wouldn't, like, put it on the map for
me?
I think I touch it.
Do I?
I gotta touch him.
Gotta touch Sweeper.
Go get him.
Yeah, go get him.
We'll watch.
Oh, he's afraid of me.
Yeah, because you want to...
Because you're trying to kill him and his kids.
I'd be afraid.
I'm not trying to kill him.
All right, come on, cat.
He left his kids!
No, he's coming back!
He's coming back!
He abandoned his children.
Well, yeah, now he has nothing to lose after you killed his
kids.
Oh, oh, shoot.
Take him back, take him back, take him back.
He has nothing to lose now.
Oh,
shoot.
Capture him.
There we go.
I need him.
Oh.
Yeah.
All right, now we go to the base.
I think we can just climb up, like, from here.
I can't ping.
I don't remember how to ping.
The whole way.
It's, like, annoying.
Yeah, you have to climb up.
I think we climb up.
We climb from here.
Yeah, we can climb up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got this.
I believe.
How many stamina levels do you guys got?
I got enough.
I'm at 240.
Oh, to be fair, man.
You're at level 27 right now.
Yeah?
Yeah.
40.
that's what i'm at actually i think i have what do i have i
have 160 stamina we got this we're fine yeah we're
practically here oh yeah i have my grapple gun oh yeah do i
have one we only have to go all the way to the very top of
that that pride rock oh yeah the pride yeah what's this
thing oh i got Wait, is it up there?
I think it's another sweeper.
Oh, wait, is it?
Another sweeper.
Is it, wait, is it up?
Is it really up on Pride Rock?
I think it's up there.
No, it's not.
No.
45 degree angle.
Wait, on the 45 degree.
That's the 45.
I thought it was over here.
It has a great view.
You have to admit.
She did.
Yeah.
So I have low render distance.
I don't care about views How do we get up there?
Oh, it's up here.
We follow the trail the trail eventually leads to the pride
rock
Okay, so they're shooting they're shooting.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's fine biting the rock.
I'm trying to get off my pal
Okay Where are you?
Oh, guys, did you see here the new update on peak?
It's like the final update.
Yeah.
Oh,
I found a way.
You found a way?
Yeah.
If there's a wheel, there's a way.
All right.
That's what I
did.
I know the way.
Oh, and the map is the same in power world for everybody.
Yeah.
It is.
I made it also the moment I make it I have to pivot to the
man I'm so I went the other way but I made it
I'm like so close there okay
okay you guys took the long long long way You guys went the
long long long way I'm literally here Oh yeah no you guys
are not making it You guys are not gonna make it You guys
are absolutely We're doing the rewarding way that's what it
is You're not you're not making it you're not making Yeah
I'm already up here Clearly, I played...
Clearly, I played Peekmore.
I can make it.
Wait, Nina, you made it.
Wait, wait.
I'm not making it.
Yes, I am!
I don't know where it is, even, though.
Wait, is it that roof right there?
Oh, you cheated.
You cheating.
Oh!
Is it here?
Wait.
Yeah, it's here.
It's here.
Don't worry about the depressed pals, though.
Don't worry about that.
Don't worry about... Oh, oh.
Don't, don't, we found them like that.
We found, they could use a little, a little love.
So, um, we think somebody.
This is what Matara Khan does to people.
Oh my god, the house looks great.
Yeah, the house looks great.
You have so many, many holes and stuff.
I'm ready to see the open air bathroom.
Wow, wow!
Oh my god, wait, this is like It's like Gerald From the
Witcher It is, Gerald Yeah, yeah If it was like a wooden
bathtub It would fit the whole vibe Why are you in the
toilet?
Oh my I'm just helping It's like the poop stick You guys
heard about the poop stick?
Yeah
have you heard about it the what the poop stick no what's
that you should google it the poop stick i'm not gonna
google that you google the bliss bliss cruise but not them
not the food standard yeah you got standards
Wait, did that work?
You heard something.
I heard, yeah.
Should we give you a surprise?
Yeah, Tui.
Wait, why would you lock me with her?
Oh,
what a nice view.
It is.
Yeah, right?
It's better than like...
Wow, this place is huge.
There's room for everybody.
I know.
She's gonna flip the house.
Don't flip it.
but think about the property value the government's gonna
want to buy it no this is all this is we pass this down to
our generations are yeah and then our kids are gonna sell it
no they wouldn't it'll last like or not it'll last like one
generation with my own hand we're gonna why are our pets so
why are our mouths so They're going to put a data center
next to it.
No.
I don't know.
I think because two of them are sleeping on the floor.
Wait, but look how many empty beds there are.
They probably can't.
I think it's probably the 40 degree angle.
It's just flying right off.
They can't sleep on it because of the 40.
That might actually be the case that they did that.
lay there and then slid off that's so sad
poor guys oh we have a mammal rest we have we have one man
tarah left this man i mean we can have more can always have
more yeah where did our merchant man go we had a merchant
man i'm on fire but it's okay i captured a merchant guy and
then i think matara took him off the base but you can sell
to him oh if you captured him i think he she has it in her
party then she wants it in her team or some shit fast as a
fiddle
oh my gosh i mean she has the merchant in her party yeah her
personal merchant rolling up with a squad of six yeah i mean
i have you could i'm i'm mad cooler man that's mine i have
these two i'm mad the first man the first man yeah look at
him go he's like possessed yeah he's possessed to chop he's
chopping down our trees he's gotta be a man he's gotta be a
man he's gotta let it out and start manning it up around
here
all right i have to go to my sponsor but you guys are still
on after an hour i'll be back i think stuffy might join in
too but i'll see you guys later bye bye have fun piling it
up guys bye bye bye all right i'm gonna let me see i'm gonna
go oh do i have any tissues i should have asked for tissues
i need to blow my nose All right, let me change my game
category and title All right, it's sponsor time Sponsor time
all right Let's see hashtag Hashtag ad so they won't get me
All right, let me find For me.
Oh, there are tissues next to me.
I know vlogging wasn't too bad, guys.
I know, it was a little scuff, but I might swap.
My other mic, I was given another microphone, but that is
louder, so I might use that microphone later if it's better.
So let me blow my nose real quick.
And then I'll put, and I'll open the call-up.
my sound team.
I abuse the sound team in the basement.
I'd be like, it's time!
It's time!
Wake up!
It's time to do sound check.
Waky, waky sound team!
My little abuse goblins.
Alright, let me blow my nose real quick.
Alright, let's see.
Yeah, get out of here and then but it will be uh let's see
will be
apparently the mod team made this for our for our manager
okay the mod team made this for him because you're like i'm
sorry man let me see if i can find it all right hope this is
the right picture um oh they shared it okay they didn't make
it sorry i was just about to like stolen valor the mod team
almost did some stolen valor shit but don't worry they
didn't make it but they shared it
It's time you learn about vacation and the importance of,
for God's sake.
I'm like, cruise!
What do you mean, the cruise?
Is that vacation?
That's a good one.
All right, apparently, Sophie is going through some
technical difficulties.
So I'll start out the sponsor off.
Start the sponsor off net for now, but let me grab the stuff
real quick Technically, it's we're not starting yet.
It's not starting yet guys.
It starts when I say we start guys Starts when I say we
start Sorry, I just downloaded a bunch of things on here and
I'm like it's gotten good to go So let me grab let me make
sure I grab everything Let's see, making sure I grab
everything for us.
Bum, bum, bum.
And then extract everything.
Where's this?
Oh, yeah.
And then grab this.
All right.
Boom.
what's this for it's the QR code for the sponsor so if you
scan that it leads you straight to downloading lead straight
to downloading the Hatsune Miku sorry so I need to blow my
nose give me a sec sponsor hasn't started yet by the way
this is not the part not the part of it I need to blow my
nose I'm very stuffy right now.
So weird.
The Hatsune Miku colorful stage!
So you can download it right now because I'll be playing
multiplayer very, very soon.
But for those who are wondering, let me see.
Let me pull up the images for you guys before I pull out
anything else.
Bapapapapapap.
Yeah!
So for those who don't know, Tamagotchi is collaborating
with Hatsune Miku Colorful Sayes so there's a lot oh I love
the art by the way the artwork is so cute ah I love the
artwork it's really really freaking cute and I'm super
excited to check out the update and all the really cute
characters and everything um and uh but they have a lot of
things in there so there's like Tamagotchi collab cards
there's gacha there's tamagashi collab items right now in my
set guy there's a tamagachi collab special stat missions and
a very special tamagachi login story and more so yeah make
sure to yes it's a collaboration between hastan miku
colorful stage and tamagachi as well so there's a lot of you
know each character has its own um collaboration character
to match up
And so make sure to download the game right now.
Oh, by the way, this is where the sponsor part starts.
But so if you click on the link pinned in the chat and are
used to command exclamation point, Miku, you can download
the game right now.
And I'll be playing with you guys.
I'm playing with dragons later on after.
Yeah, we're going to do some pulls.
We're going to play some of the new songs there and
everything.
there's the Tamagotchi gotcha the dream gotcha so drop rates
are now increased for 10 crossover exclusive characters I
think the capo one is my favorite so you can see that you
see all the virtual singers with their chosen collaborate I
love the art by the way the art is so fucking cute oh yeah
oh yeah by the way okay let me open the basement door real
quick hey hey wake up sound team It's time My new abuse
sound Yeah Wake up To work goblins It's time It's time to do
more sound checks
Get up Anyway
Anyway There's a couple of really fun collaborations, so
check out the Colorful Stage X Tamagotchi crossover login
store, and it's going to be on August 4th to the 13th, so
there's still time to check it out.
Why are they all depressed?
They have beds.
Exactly!
If it works for the sound team, it works for the pals.
so there's also like these like i said earlier there's a
crossover gachi charm exchange so this is like for my sakai
uh and so you see all these like tamagachi uh uh tamagachi
outfits you can get for my sakai and everything and then
there's also wow the stamp missions too so you have all
these clear missions and then the stamp cards clear missions
and fill out your stamp card earn crossover blueprints rice
balls and gachi charms and remember it goes from august 4th
um to august 13 so you have a week less than a week left so
make sure you get in on the collaboration or it's gone
forever and you oh sorry sorry i sound guy or it's gone
forever sorry maybe i got a little too passionate there um
let's see what oh so we're um we're gonna try and we're
gonna start play okay let me let's see if this works all
right sound team you ready and this is the moment of truth
okay let me how do i all right it's the moment of truth i
already logged in don't worry guys i already logged in i'm
so locked in I'm gonna, let's see, I'm gonna take this away,
the keyboard away, and I'm gonna perch it a little bit
higher too so I can, boy, I forgot how to do this.
Give me a second.
You gotta perch up the iPad so I can tap it correctly.
Oh my God, I can't see, okay, I'm just putting, I'm just
gonna lay on the, I'm gonna lay it there.
You can see me look down, I don't care.
All right, let's see.
All right, let me.
All right, sound team.
It's time.
I'm ready.
All right.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Bum, bada, bada, bada.
Bum, bada, bum.
Okay, we'll put this.
here so then there's the qr code there you go put it here
for the qr code all right all right well we all know what i
want to do first oh there is crossover stamp missions so we
got this i got logged in claim all give me everything so i
get everything all right we gotta remember claim your stamps
and then oh this is It's so bad.
That's oh and then here the crossover stuff.
So I have a $32 for now, but don't worry Don't worry.
We always let it ride.
All right.
Gotcha.
So oh, they're so cute.
I'm sorry, but this is actually like They're actually
they're so cute.
I actually love I don't know who I actually really want to
know who the artist is because I love the artwork.
I actually want artwork from this artist like I want this
artist to like To like make art for me.
Alright, it's time to let it.
It is!
They're so cute!
And the best part is, Kaito is not involved!
That's the best part!
Real and true.
Can't mess with me this time!
You must be so distant.
We can do this.
All right.
Let's pull.
Wait, what?
No, I do have it.
Insufficient paint.
But I have so much.
What do you mean?
What's the point of having 60,000?
Wait.
No.
There doesn't you have.
Wait, I must have, oh, the non-paid, there you go, pull,
there you go, oh, it's fine, I have 60K regular ones, oh,
wait, that's yellow, you know what that means,
all right, show me the money, Okay, I don't care about you.
You're not Tamagotchi.
Oh my god Whatever oh my
Twice in a row root there he is there he is oh That's cute.
That's cute.
I like that Okay, can we get three?
Where's my Tamagotchi?
It's fine.
They make you work for it so it it's like so it feels better
when you get him you know there he is look duke your
favorite virtual singer right there okay that's gold
i'm a no tamagashi's forever tamagashi's always been there
for you okay i am a fuyu minori Kito Minori Oh, okay at
least she's cute.
No, that's fine.
That's not she's cute.
That's fine.
It's not.
It's not Kaito That's fine.
Exactly.
You know how long Tamagotchi's been?
Tamagotchi is older than Kaito Okay, oh Miki Miki gun.
Oh, she has a gun.
I like that Here you go.
Here's another blue hair character We did it what the f-
Akita, what are you doing?
Oh my God, okay, whatever.
Oh my, she wasn't even done.
Please, I wanna let me look at her.
She wasn't even done.
She wasn't done talking.
And Akita's like, hey there, what about me?
Akita jumpscare, the interrupt.
Bro, she wasn't done.
I'm even done talking!
Um...
As the Costco is looking down, I bet you're not on the mic.
Oh, shit, okay.
Let me... Alright, apparently looking down is bad.
Ha ha ha!
My sound team is like, please stop looking down.
It's so hard to balance.
Alright.
Let me...
I have an idea.
All right, here we go I need a balance between all right.
There we go.
I'm no longer looking I'm sort of I'm still looking down But
like It's you know, we're making it work
We're making I have so many pull I can do this forever All
right, but that's not yellow though Okay, Mizuki ah, okay
her again um okay luca ari oh we got the main cat we have
mamachi i got that's a four star what's the five star then
oh she's so cute she's like you're free now little guy be
free oh purple is but but i'm yellow can't be yellow equals
gold what is purple equal to what kind of crystal is purple
all right we pull again we gotta keep let it ride
all right we got her we've got this before oh we got it
again okay now I can actually hear her she's I love I love
the artwork for this it's so cute look at them enjoying some
little pastries uh we'll make sure you're heard over and
also miku noises okay so bring the game a little bit up i
got you okay all right sound team i brought the game a
little up okay akira haruka oh swimsuit oh ina len luka all
right pull again we don't stop until we got all of them i
can pull days all right who's next i don't know it's like
why is purple better what has purple given us we have like
might as well be rose gold
mafu you ah it must suck for the tamagachi to be like uh
regulated as the non-gold stars Purple is royalty.
All right, again.
Again.
Let it ride.
I don't have karaoke to stop me from Gacha in this time.
That's right.
Karaoke doesn't stop me.
Let it ride.
oh it's the apple i'm really bad at tomagachi um how i think
like the last time i played tomagachi is when like tom when
i was a little uh kid also sound guy brought the game up a
little bit so let me know if it's better but when i was a
little kid and kept turning into poop i'm so bad at taking
care of them why is it just yellow now now that i know
purple is better it's okay i still have so many wait how
many tamagachis am i missing anyway there's
like five right wait i want to see i have oh i don't have oh
wait are these the five stars guys like these are the five
stars right
Oh, forest eyes?
Because I haven't seen these artwork yet.
Oh, wait, how do I get these artwork for it?
Okay, I have...
Yeah, I have her.
I don't have Chino.
Then, bonus details.
Oh!
I guess they're like bonus, like, they're just like bonus
artwork.
Because I thought it would be like...
Oh!
it's the highest oh oh are these the second art is that the
second art i love the second art they're so cute i don't
know i don't know what this artist is but i love this artist
it's so cute and this is what my favorite this is my
favorite artist right now in this game i don't know i just
oh i just i want i want artwork from this artist yeah is
this the second artwork that you have to unlock because that
would make sense because i was like i need two more I need
two more from the Tamagotchi series.
And then we should be good.
I'll need to blow my nose again.
Alright, they want me to bring up the game a little bit
more.
Alright, sound team.
I brought up the game a little bit more.
Alright, pull again.
Don't worry, I still have so much.
I got this, guys.
Alright, Rio.
I like how I pulled Kaido like twice in one one pull and
then he's never came back oh that's cute sorry so this is
Morimoto yeah that's new oh this is so cute I never I love
all the collabs I love like how games have been doing more
collabs and stuff lately with like a bunch of different
franchises I don't know crossover sells honestly
I don't care you're not Tamagotchi I can pull you whenever
oh okay we already have her
all right oh it's land abracadabra now you can say it oh
kindness in a ribbon okay Okay, oh, she's new.
I like how they cut the Tamagotchi.
She's like, but this is my stage.
And she's just like, yeah, I know we have a collab, but the
eyes on me.
The Tamagotchi is just like cut halfway.
Shagot.
Oh.
Okay, there's only two more.
Come on, baby.
I said, I have so many gems.
Oh my, get out of here.
Oh my god!
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
He's just, I did like 20 pulls and this is the fourth time
he showed up.
Like, I gotta take what I can get.
It's summer.
Girl, you gotta fix your calendar.
Why are you still at school?
At summer vacation.
Are you stupid?
Are you at summer school?
The sleight of him makes my blood boil.
All right.
Next pull!
Oh my god, come on!
I'm missing two more!
I gotta complete the collection!
I can get you any other day!
Oh, we're running low.
now but but I had so many I had there was so many in my how
could this be oh I like this it's like the comic panel oh
there's Suzuki again I don't understand how where did it all
go
they can't just do this to me they can't just give me like
two Tamagotchi and then beat it and they're like the first
one's free they can't do this to me they can't give me that
rush and then leave me to dry like this they gotcha give it
this gotcha take it are you did you like it I'm still
pulling what do you think oh okay I like that card all right
Don't worry, don't worry.
I still have so many.
I have so many.
Don't worry.
I have pals to come home to after.
I have pals to come after.
The sound team is still in the basement.
Do you hear that sound team?
after.
Cozy.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
We had a great stream.
Knock, knock.
Backstage operator.
Me-couping emo.
Sometimes they don't know who's a pal and who's sound guy.
Alright, sound Team said bring the game up a little bit more
Is the QR code distracting?
Don't worry, I got you Is it better now?
What do I put in just on my, is it better?
I'm so sorry my face was distracting you guys.
I hope this helps more.
Anyway, you scan the You scan the QR code You can download
the game right now for all the free for some free stuff.
Don't you guys love free stuff?
There we go.
Is that better now?
All right, let's do don't we have so many we have so many
But yeah, remember to download the game right now Click on
the link pinned in the chat or do exclamation point Miku or
scan the QR code and we're gonna be doing some multiplayer
games later well please don't forget sound guy your chat is
to my left oh you're making me angry sound team I can't face
the microphone when you're to my left they're like please
don't oh
Let's see one one last pull Don't get let me get my belt
Okay,
Minori my Huyu I depressed Michael sorry emo Michael At
least I got Ren out of it.
I like Ren Ren's a cutie.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
I would have liked to get the kappa though I think the one
that would, I mean, I got Memechi and, uh, is that a sheet?
Uh, let's see.
Yeah, I would have liked to get, I would have liked to get,
uh, I really want Kappa.
I think he's really cute.
I know that's, like, Duby's favorite as well, but I think
he's the cutest out of all of them.
Go to Exchange?
Which one's Exchange?
Do I have, do I have Peabody?
Do I have anything here that I can use?
Two?
Yeah, I can do one pull.
Guys, maybe it's the one pull dream.
Maybe it's the one pull dream.
I still have one more.
Maybe it's the one.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'm not.
Not.
It's okay.
It's fine!
Might need to go to basement real soon, guys.
Melody, thank you for the 11, uh, for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, thank you for the raid.
Oh, you had a great stream.
Thank you, thank you.
We're playing Hatsune Miku.
Colorful Steve!
The Tamagachi collab right now.
Alright, let me double check.
Alright, I think...
Let's see.
Alright, I can...
I can level up...
I can start leveling up my Tamagotchi characters.
I remember how to do this.
Okay, we're gonna get rid of you.
And then put in...
I'm gonna put in...
I'm gonna put in her?
Wait, why are you a leader?
Wait a minute.
Wait, who replaced you?
What did I do?
Okay.
I wanted her, I wanted him out.
Get out, why are you here?
Who invited you?
I can't have both of them though.
No, I can't, all right.
I have to invite her.
I wanna invite, you'll always be here.
Ah, oh wait, I can't, wait, is that Miku?
God damn it, I forgot that's Miku, but what if she has white
hair?
I forgot she was Miku, but her hair was white.
I was like, who's this girl?
Who's she?
That's Miku with white hair.
God damn it, she got me.
She was in witness protection.
I didn't realize that was just her with white hair.
I was like, what if she has hetochromia eyes and white hair?
Let's see.
All right, it's time to...
Oh, wait, are there any new songs?
Let's see.
I'm trying to remember...
Where's the shop?
The shopping mall.
All right, the music shop.
Most...
Wait.
Can I buy...
Okay.
what are the costumes i can buy um oh i don't know if i want
any new costumes i like all the cost she has so many
costumes i i'm sorry girl like i i'm not made of money girl
like i'm sorry this is the i already bought you clothes you
want more than one set of clothes you crazy all right all
right let's buy some is it different music unlock songs of
your other characters.
Let's see.
Oh, they have Queen.
Wait.
Music shop.
What's the difference between music shop and what's the
difference between music shop and cover shop, guys?
So all my veterans out there.
So all my Hatsune Miku colorful stage veterans.
Guys, I spent all my money on the cruise, guys.
Oh,
they're alternative versions.
Oh, so, like, there's some of these songs.
Oh, but they're different singers.
Oh, I see.
Oh, that's cute.
I don't know that.
Okay, that's good to know.
That's it.
I want to do, like, new songs.
All right, let's...
These are all new...
Okay, when did I last bought songs?
I'm trying to remember.
I think it's here.
Because there's...
I don't have...
Is it here?
When did I last buy songs?
I don't remember if I saw a queen.
I don't think I saw a queen.
I know like...
Uh...
Okay, what is this?
It's released.
Try to remember when I last bought songs.
Is it after?
We did see Queen already?
Okay, so we are around here somewhere.
So I'm going to buy new songs that I have.
But I'm going to buy songs that I know.
Which is a little hard.
I mean, we all know Mesmerizer.
Alright, let's buy Mesmerizer just because I can't.
Alright, buy Mesmerizer.
So we all know Mesmerizer.
Let's see, change, snooze.
Yeah, that's a banger.
I never heard of this one.
Oh, wait, is this...
I love this song!
Okay, this is my favorite.
This is my favorite Snow Miku songs.
I love Snow Miku.
I have that, I actually have that on my phone.
See, oh shit, AI.
They have AI?
Nobody's safe from AI.
Oh my, no one's safe.
Oh no.
What's this?
This
is good AI.
I bet that one.
I like that song.
Let's see.
Queen of Hearts.
Wait, is this the one I know?
I this is familiar so I'm gonna buy it.
I I don't exactly know This I don't know it's familiar.
I'm not really sure sure of the song, but like I it It's I
know I've heard it before That's how I'm going on with this.
It's like I know I've heard this song before.
I don't know exactly where But I've heard your song Why I
dance is a banger.
I don't know if I've heard listen to that song song before I
want to do songs that like oh wait no I don't know this okay
let's see I'm gonna go all the way down and see if there's
any other songs that I might know and I haven't bought it
yet I just like I don't know I just want to play songs that
I've like listened to like that I know the songs of hello
how are you wait let's see reload it oh wait is this oh
that's a that's an oldie but a banger oldie that's a oh is
it give me
Yeah, patchwork is fired.
That, it's like, oh.
Oh my god, they're all like big oldies, but let's see.
Oh, Rolling Girl.
Are we in Rolling Girl?
Uh, yeah, the classics.
We're doing the classics here.
All the classics.
Is there any Tamagotchi?
collab song that thing I really check um or is it just
character I think it's just characters right I don't want to
be sure oh my gosh I realize I forgot something alright guys
I almost forgot something alright let me we're supposed to
where you have to watch a video about the collab i caught
myself before it was too late i think it's this one let me
double check though oh i forgot we gotta do the video i
didn't forget i didn't forget it was just i put it in the
wrong order you know that's different you know uh putting
something in the wrong order does That mean I forgot, it's
just, I just placed it in a different order of the stream,
you know?
I think it's this video, let me double check.
Oh, it is, all right.
All right, I gotta make sure.
Yeah, I'll make sure.
And then, uh,
I haven't watched this video yet.
Eglipid Collaboration!
Mamachini!
and that guy and Gucci and also these other six guys
Kuchipachi!
Mementi is that guys?
This guy and Kuchipachi!
The ones that...
I don't...
You can tell how I don't have a favorite.
Anyway, back to music.
Guys, I don't have a favorite.
They're already, yeah, they're all in my Sakai.
You can have them in my Sakai too All right, okay, okay,
okay.
I'll buy one more song and we play we can play some
multiplayer Let's see it.
Yeah
That guy that guy
Yes, yes, yes All right, all right now.
Okay, wait one more one more song one more song I got up my
collection here
What else
Okay, let's bring the game some more Okay, let's have a say
we gotta bring the oh, it's cuz also apparently because I
stare at the game too Yeah, bring the game up a little bit
more and then fix my Did I fix my game filter by two?
All right, this is where I got you guys.
All right, I did it.
I fixed it by two.
What's the?
All right, one more mute song and then.
All right, guys, remember to download the game, guys.
Remember to click on the link pinned in the chat or scan the
QR code.
This is a final call before I start the games.
Final call.
Let's see, oh, I won't buy this.
No, never mind, I don't want to buy it.
I thought it was a different song.
Yes.
I thought it was a different song, so I was like, ooh, is it
that song?
And it was not that song.
I'm sorry.
But I got confused, there's so many songs.
Alright, now we can play.
I don't remember what four were the new songs I bought.
So we're gonna, we're gonna do it live.
Alright, I'm trying to remember how to do this.
Uh, how do I...
Show, there you go.
Co-op.
Is it co-op?
Yes, we're all working together.
Oh shit.
Hold on.
All right, don't worry.
All right, guys, I'm creating room.
Get ready.
Nine, six, seven, two, one.
Get in here.
Get it over here.
All right, oh shit.
I have to select the song.
How much time do I have?
Um, oh, room disbanded.
It was my room.
How is the room disbanded?
This was my room!
I- Who gave you a right to the span my own room?
Oh, Victor, thank you for the 250s, thank you, thank you!
Alright, here you go.
Alright, now I got- where are my new songs?
Where are the new songs that I bought?
Oh, shit.
I don't remember which- Oh my god!
Alright.
Release.
Okay, it should be by release, right?
Guys!
I'm- no, it's fine!
Alright.
Okay, that's fine.
Wow, who would- who would have thought- Who would have
thought?
Who would have thought he would win?
Oh my god.
Oh, I forgot to adjust the speed.
Someone said I- Oh, okay.
It's fine.
Everything's fine.
Everything- Everything is fine Don't worry We're so, we're
fine I'm so prepared I'm so prepared to The fucking game I
forgot how fast this goes Alright, here we go Oh my god, how
do I play this again Okay No!
Wait!
Oh my god!
Why is it so fast?
I'm not ready.
I'm still alive, right?
I'm so healthy What difficulty am I on?
Who selected this who selected this on?
We're so healthy
See every I'm so healthy I know it says zero, but it's like
a little bug I'm actually like 500 hp
Oh, yeah, I'm gaming.
I can't fuck this up.
I did 153 combo.
153 combo.
Wow.
What a carry.
Oh, my gosh.
It's so hard carrying my team right now.
I got 153 combo.
Oh, don't worry.
Oh, beaver.
by the way.
And girls, girls, simmered down.
There's plenty of jokie to go around.
After all the card carry I just did for the team.
Oh my god, don't worry.
I got you guys.
One at a time.
Ladies, ladies.
It was very hot.
See me play that song, wasn't it?
All right.
I know.
Oh, wow.
All right.
Another room.
Nine, eight.
Okay.
Let's actually let me adjust.
JK.
Let me adjust the speed.
I can make sure.
This is the right speed I'm supposed to be on.
Alright, let's do...
Wait.
Is it note speed?
9.
Okay.
We're trying 9.
I think 10 was a little too ambitious for me.
Oh.
It was a little too ambitious.
Oh yeah, by the way, when you click on the link, um check
out the web shop uh so at the top right and you can and the
first purchase comes with a 20 crystal bonus so if you guys
already signed up uh via my link or pinned in my chat or
exclamation point nico or scan the qr code you get 20 off on
crystal bonus just remember that guys all right here we go
all right it's still the same number 98237 all right let's
Alright, let's try, let's try, like, more.
Because I know you guys are so impressed.
I gotta do another one.
I know you guys were like, Whoa!
Don't, don't, come down!
Leave some room for the rest of the rest of us Hatsune Miku
colorful stage players.
Oh!
Alright, we might have to create a new room.
Sorry, guys.
Alright.
9, 2, 3, 5, 9.
9, 2, 3, 3, 5, 9, 9, 2, 3, 5, 9, 2, 3, 5, 9, I mean, you can
see it down there, honestly.
Hey, shoot him on in here.
Nobody select anything.
Nobody select any song.
This is my show.
This is my private.
Hey, hey, boy.
I'm gonna click your info profile after this game.
I'm gonna block you!
That's it!
You better play on expert.
What?
Who was it?
Who did that?
Was it then?
I actually don't even remember.
I know I said I was gonna remember the name, but I already
forgot.
I was like, I will remember you.
I was not.
gonna remember you you're nothing to me how I would I
remember you if you didn't select a song how dare you oh wow
that's right oh my gosh who's not loading in who's not
loading in guys hello all right Tatoris I like the song
though I let the re like how they're they remix the Tetris
theme to do this
what difficulty I'm actually on expert
I know it's definitely expert level oh my god oh my look at
these fingers go whoa
Oh my god.
Oh you can barely see my fingers going it's so fast Look at
that Oh my god, it's like going 80 buttons for 80 presses
per minute per second
I lied it was an expert it might have been like the hardest
difficulty I know, how does she do it?
Oh my god, I barely lost any lives.
Oh, don't worry guys.
Oh, I know.
Oh, calm down.
Simmer down, ladies, ladies.
Simmer down, I know.
Wow.
We're gonna look at those fingers.
Go.
Going 80 miles per hour.
Look at that.
Not last, too.
Wow, and then I was about to catch up with you, then.
Maybe you gotta get better.
Look at that, you see that?
It's on, it was on Masters.
Did you see that, guys?
Oh, wow.
I know I can't believe it I hit masters oh my god that was
crazy I lost track of like how fast my fingers were going
there it was so fast all right let's do now we get to the
song I want to do thank you good god thank you I know it
wasn't that hard you're doing a legendary line up dragons
line up all right single by the way all right come on guys I
know you're all very intimidated I know nine six two one
four I know after my performance just now I know you're so
intimidated by me you're like oh man how can I possibly do
better than that but don't worry guys I believe don't don't
worry they don't want to get help come on oh don't be scared
all right who the fuck selected this song All right, you
know what?
Let's try it Can't be that bad, but you know what?
It actually could be that bad All right, here we go
What do you mean I selected legendary?
I was I was just like should I do a lesser difficulty?
Just to make my dragon not feel that bad.
Oh my god, look at that.
She's cheering me on.
Damn right you are.
Oh, ladies.
.
Nice.
This might be the first time I've listened to this song
fully.
I've seen all the memes and the artwork.
I like the artwork, art style of this and the music video
and the stuff I've seen.
Oh my god, dude.
I can't believe I just pressed like 900 notes just now.
How does she do it?
This is a
good song.
It's my first time listening to it fully.
Oh my god.
They wish they were like me.
Look at that combo.
Oh.
I didn't die at once.
Look at that.
That didn't drop a single combo.
Oh man.
I know don't get too intimidated guys.
Just a prodigy.
You know?
Just a newcomer prodigy in the scene.
No big deal or anything.
Yeah.
Yeah, I first tried that, look at that.
On Expert too.
Yeah, first try that song, first time.
On Expert, how does she do it?
I don't know.
We don't reveal a secret, you know?
A magician doesn't reveal their secrets, guys.
All right, we'll do another one.
I heard Snuffy got it, Got her technical difficulty sorted
out, but while we wait, I don't know if she still wants to
do it.
We could do some
Let's see While we wait for it.
Let's check out my second guy What I'll visit somebody's
house Guys, all right, whose house who wants to flex your
house?
What are you doing here?
Who invited you over here?
For how to walk.
Oh, here.
How do I go to people's houses?
It was like right here.
How is it?
How do I visit someone's house?
I don't remember.
It's been a while since I broke into someone's house.
Oh,
she's running it solo.
I wonder if she's down for one game.
Alright, how do you...
How do you visit someone's house in this game?
I don't remember.
I don't know if this is someone's tech guy.
Guys, I can't alt F4 a fucking tablet.
to here
I don't remember just tell me to build up my sec guy but I
just want to steal someone else's sec guy and be like this
is my home guys I made this
does anyone does no one want to visit your house guys come
on does no one want me to visit your house What are you
scared?
You scared of showing your house?
What are we gonna do?
Laugh at it?
I mean, maybe, but come on, gotta be brave.
You always, well, if you know I always judge you, then you
wouldn't mind me judging you.
You wouldn't mind if I judge you, if you know what's going
to happen.
That's all I'm saying.
Fine.
Going once.
It's over.
That's right.
You lost your chance of getting judged.
You lost your chance.
I could have judged you fair and square.
Look at that.
Oh my god, Clayball.
Oh nice, yay.
More money.
Yippee, free stuff.
You guys like free stuff?
Remember to click on the link or scan the QR code or use
exclamation point Miku.
And remember, if you check out the web store, you get 20%
crystal bonus on your first purchase, guys.
And also, also, by the way, bonus stuff, bonus stuff.
Make sure to check up Colorful Stage Social and they're
TikToks too.
We have a TikTok.
You guys didn't know that.
That's right.
I'm going to flex the TikTok videos.
Yeah, check out their TikTok.
Give them a follow.
All right, we're going to goosh my link too, guys.
All right, we'll do two more songs.
All right, 80709.
All right.
In your Wi-Fi.
Hey there.
I'm not done yet.
I want to do the shrimp song.
Who let her pick a sock?
Are you kidding me?
Fuck it.
You know what?
Let's try it.
Let's try.
Who was it?
Who did that?
Who picked the song?
Who gave you the right?
This is my room.
You don't just go into someone's house and then turn on,
change someone's channel.
I was robbed of my shrimp.
Oh shit.
I don't even know the song.
I've never heard of this song before, I'm sad.
I'm more like a old school Vocaloid fan.
I don't keep up, I don't know.
I don't keep up with a lot with the newer Vocaloid virtual
singer songs.
Except for the ones that go like super viral, like
mesmerized.
like you can't really avoid it like the songs that get the
gap figures you know
the ones that like everyone does cover music for hey this is
not bad I've
never heard of this one before is it niche or like it's just
like if you're in the community you know the songs like you
know Like I used to watch nico nico videos of like like a
meat like this is how nico nico videos of like They're
called mads, right?
They used to be called mads of the older vocal vocaloid song
Okay, you nerds.
I see all the combos there.
This is not your first time playing the song
Okay, nerds, that's right.
Why don't you first try a song like me?
Damn, yeah, I don't believe that's your first time.
I bet you played this song like 800 million times.
Nerds.
They're just good at it.
Yeah, see, I'm a natural boy in Friday, you know, I can,
yeah, that was my first time attempt, you know?
Yeah Yeah, whatever Why are you hating?
Maybe you truly want to flex do the hardest difficulty Are
you want to flex do the hard they're caring?
Um, excuse me.
I'm caring them.
All right, play the hardest difficulty.
If you join my room, you better play.
We all love Kaito.
All right.
Do the hardest.
Okay.
Pick the hardest.
What's the hardest song, guys?
What's the hardest song in Hasune Miku?
Colorful Sage.
What's the hardest song, guys?
And do the hardest difficult.
I'll join you too in solidarity
All right, choose it choose the hardest song I'll let you
pick That's right the hardest song and do the hardest
difficulty don't be a pussy now That's why I'm watching you
guys select your difficulty Man select it Master, get out of
there!
What do you mean hard?
I meant master.
I know it goes beyond hard.
I .
Well, he has all hard difficulty.
I said the hardest.
That's it.
What's going on?
I'm so alive, right?
Am
I alive?
I'm so healthy.
I bet you I'm so healthy right now.
I'm practically in perfect health.
Okay, we're okay.
We're so, we're, we're, we're, we're here.
There's more to this.
Okay, perfect.
What?
Don't buy.
I'm so healthy.
Don't worry, God, ladies, don't worry, God, my back hurts so
much right now, oh, oh my, oh, don't need to thank me,
ladies, ladies, don't need to thank me, I know, oh, you're
welcome, everyone, you're welcome, you're so welcome, I So
oh and a new record too.
Oh See easiest s rank of my life
We're snub yo she had technical difficulties I heard she's
on I messaged her I'll call her too.
I'm really good the peekaboo Let's call it
Oh She's not picking up.
She got super peekabooed
She's not picking up Oh, she might have streamer mode on
that's must be a cat peekaboo her if she fucking knows guys
How am I supposed to peek?
Oh, yeah, by the way Sound team Um, if the game got a little
louder, it's because I turned back on Uh, my other game.
Oh, Snuffy!
I heard you guys everything fixed.
What the hell?
Are you put?
What?
Hello?
Don't you remember?
It's supposed to be a color.
I feel like I just joined a circus.
What's going on?
Oh, do you hear it?
Do you hear?
Yay!
The bear's here.
Oh, you hear it!
Doki!
What's going on?
What is this?
I see here's the game bugger.
There you go.
All right.
Hey, what was that?
That was a, that was a, that was a, that was a, it's Hatsune
Miku called for stage.
If you guys want to know what song she was listening to,
make sure to click the link pinned in my chat or snuffie's
chat or scan the QR code or use exclamation point Miku and
download, click on the link and download.
the game i know i'm so good at this i oh my god have you
already done your stuff have you done the yeah i just
started i'm gonna cry give me a sec my tablet closed down
guys like my default my yeah my lock screen that i never
changed like oh my god oh man i'm so jealous i wanted
everybody to see my vanilla lock screen yeah i yeah they're
like caught and it was like literally just default lock
screen that i never changed since i got the ipad we know you
have the notes app installed no it was my lock screen you
know like the default wallpaper the two orbs yeah yeah all
right and you remember how to I keep how do I use my
passcode why won't it let me passcode oh my god did you wait
your game crash is that what you said no I had to I I did
touch the pad pretty long enough so I have to I'm trying to
unlock my iPad man oh there it is unlocked it you fixed it
um it's good enough you know it's good enough I got it I got
it good enough all right you should join let's 1v1 let's at
least have a little bit a little bit of the collaboration
you wait you're not even you're not wait what you don't even
have a character what have you been doing I I was just given
my lengthy intro it was about to watch the video oh you're
about to watch the video you watch so yeah my capture card I
was gonna I was just like exploded when i tried to change
the resolution so i i was like locked in like a purgatory
for like an hour trying to fix it so it's okay according to
plan i'm not even don't worry i'm not even using i'm not
even at home you're not even at home is that why you sound
like you're in like a room right now i'm what do you mean
we're all in a room your natural habitat we're all we're all
in a room what the fuck does that mean actually i'm outside
right now i'm in i'm in a room yeah i am in a room i okay
well how do i queue up how do i are you in the lobby are you
in the lobby we all get at least are you in the lobby i'm in
the lobby are you in the lobby okay give me a all right give
me a sec because i i fucked up a little bit well i somehow
probably not nearly as much as me so don't worry because my
game i don't hear game sound anymore what happens in my game
sound oh my god that happened to me too okay give me a sec
uh sec guy i get it no i slap you on the wrist i slap you on
the wrist you kick me You can't do that.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
It's my Sakai.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, it says I'm talking about my
Sakai.
What?
You're just like you're, are you just speaking Japanese?
No, you not.
No, someone didn't.
Someone didn't read.
Someone didn't.
I did read.
That's why I told you.
Look at, look at, look at my Sakai.
Look at it.
What?
Look at my Sakai.
Someone didn't read.
Someone didn't read if you don't know what my Sakai is.
What?
Someone didn't do their homework.
Someone didn't do their homework!
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, I'm waiting.
I see, I see.
I was, I did my homework.
I did my homework.
Oh, you tried to, but you slapped my wrist.
You slapped my wrist when you shouldn't have.
You shouldn't have slapped my wrist.
Because I knew what I was doing.
But you're like, no, no, you did something not.
And I was like, what do you...
I never execute anything accordingly.
So this should be expected.
You broke my game.
So I'm clicking my Sakai.
Yeah.
Why are you clicking my Sakai?
I didn't tell you to click it.
I thought that's like what you had to do.
No, I was just making a funny joke.
Oh, that was fucking a win with me too.
I was making a play on words.
A new Sakai is about to be born.
Did you know that?
Yeah, I did.
I did, actually.
That's you.
I didn't know they were born.
I upped Snuffy's volume a little bit.
So let me know if it's better.
Let me be loud.
Oh, you're loud.
Okay, I need to figure out how to fix mine.
Give me a sec.
Now, somebody...
Yeah, no, take your time.
Take your time.
Somebody broke my game.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Snuffy?
Snuffy, are you okay?
oh it's me not you it's me don't worry it's me not you oh
I'm 5,000 MS I'm 5,000 MS my I'm not coming back in okay
wait why is my game not working now I blame snuffing it was
fine I swear it was so fine and then I called her and then
it was no longer fine something happened here yeah I'm back
I'm back welcome back question mark yeah um give me a second
i blame your you're you're like you said something about
like oh my god about what about what my game's not making
music anymore yeah i thought maybe your connection drop no
oh yeah my i went to 5 000 ms for some reason okay let me
maybe if i i don't know how to move i know what to do i
don't know what to do Alright you go do your tutorial.
I don't even think you did your tutorial yet.
Tutorial?
I think the tutorial?
I think it was required to make an account.
You do your tutorial?
Do your gotcha pools.
Okay okay I'm gonna go do a gotcha pool.
You gotcha pools while I fix this.
I'm trying to make sure I have some volume going in.
Let's see the gotcha pool.
Yeah?
Is is um Tamagachi It's a tamagachi collab Yeah, but what's
it called?
What's like the name for it?
It's tamagachi No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no I got it my
music is working.
All right, get out of there.
Get out of there.
We're co-opping.
They have to download something to pull the gotcha.
Get out!
We gotta fight!
Wait, what?
You just said they pulled the got a gotcha.
We fight and then you pull up This is more important
What are you doing right now?
I'm looking at the gotcha.
I'm about to school you with my epic character.
I'm going to pool.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, right Do you like Tamagotchi don't you?
I do.
I used to I played when I was a kid and they all turned into
poop No, they all turned into they all I'll turn it into...
I was a child!
I could barely take care of myself, let alone a second...
Let alone a creature.
Yeah, because they're like, feed me, feed me!
Every, like, 10 minutes?
I'm a child!
You expect a child to be able to handle that responsibility?
Children yearn for little, like, baby toys to simulate
having, like, a maturity feeling.
I feed them when I can feed them.
I really want I want this one or maybe this green one people
pachi um I'll play a song while I wait alright dragons wait
did you fix it?
I thought you said you were on your town no I said I fixed
it and I said come in here 1B1B I don't need to Okay, I'm
okay.
You know what?
Yeah, 1v1 me or unless you're a coward.
I want to
1v1 me unless you're a coward.
Oh, we should do a collab room.
How do we do a collab room again?
I don't remember how this how to do it Hey zero you have to
do the right side the far right Because the far right you
see that one get oh my oh what what the news the one gear T
three star hot no okay close that okay you see oh yeah oh oh
oh yeah yes yes I get stressed out I get stressed out I lose
the ability to reading function thank you for your poor
grandma I'm assuming this is bad because it's not like
rainbows all right wait let's we should do a collab room
because we're powering next right yes all right we're
palling it up after how do i do this collaborate love how do
i knock on your door you better not you better stay away
from i'm knocking we're not sharing should we share a chat
oh ichi gachi Oh, are you on Twitch today?
Yeah, I'm on Twitch today.
Do I share my chat with you or not?
Yeah, come on in.
Make yourself comfortable.
I'm sharing my chat.
Knock, knock.
Yay, yay, yay.
Get in here.
Knock, knock.
Don't you have to give me like a link?
I knocked on your door.
I don't know what that means.
Nobody's ever knocked on my door.
I don't know what it means either.
I'm not on Twitch!
Okay, I'm sending it.
I'm looking.
Oh, I see.
I see.
I said, okay, knock knock.
There we go.
Why are you talking to me through this?
Who's at my door today?
Oh my god.
Knock, knock.
Okay, now we're combined.
There you go.
Dude, I'm not getting...
You're a fake Twitch streamer.
You're a LARPer.
You're a LARP.
You're a Twitch larper.
I can't keep up with the updates, man.
I'm too old for this.
That's why your grandpa, Valworld.
I literally am so old.
All right.
Oh my god, this is the first time.
Oh yeah, because I didn't share chat last time.
I was like, keep the demons away.
Because we're playing.
Hello little dokey birdlings.
Because we were playing.
Oh my god, it's Kaito.
Oh, he's my favorite.
Okay, I'm going to end.
I'm going to end the collab.
I'm going to.
What?
What's up against men?
What was your favorite?
What the heck?
Goodbye.
You guys, dragons, don't get near them.
Don't get near them.
No, no.
Streaming support Kaito.
I need that for myself.
Omega?
We gotta, we gotta end it here.
I'm sorry guys.
I don't wanna, sorry.
You know when you're like, when you're like the moms don't
want the kids to hang out with the other kid, because
they're like.
But the kaito is like a hello HR.
Like what, he's so cool.
I don't know, I don't think they have the, like a Gakupo or
whatever his name was.
He was cool.
Oh, what?
Oh, this looks cool.
Real fans will know what I mean.
Yeah, first she's a raccoon.
Now she likes kite tail.
You know, sometimes you have to sacrifice things, you know,
for the great.
You have to sacrifice things for the great again.
Somehow I choose the wrong path every time.
I like the wrong dial, like the wrong dialogue options.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, snuffie.
My mom says I can't come over here anymore.
don't hang out with that family I hear they listen to Kaiko
yeah I hear they like Kaiko don't this is a meeku only
household dude I can't pull one of the features just keep
pulling I'm trying I'm trying what only one this time oh my
god oh my god just keep pulling you gotta let it ride unless
you're a quitter unless you're a loser I don't No, I'm gonna
beat you.
What do you mean beat me?
I already finished.
I technically already finished my part.
But you love me so much.
You love me so much.
You just want to spend time with me.
I ended the collab room.
What?
Did you not notice?
You took the kids.
Did you not?
Did you not notice the shared chat was gone?
I walked into my pools right now.
There's no way bring me back bring me back.
I know you knock you knock on my door How do I knock you
knock on my door?
Why am I knocking?
I'm knocking you're knocking me in all right fine Long at
your door
Don't you chat don't don't don't don't let her take you away
from me I swear I'll get a good pool I swear you didn't even
combine the two chats you didn't wait how do i do that you
didn't even know that wait wait oh my god start sharing
because it's caring okay they're back oh my god they're back
welcome back rooftop chat the divorce kids are back how does
the pity kick in oh my god wait that was green Wait, that
was probably good, right?
No, purple is the best.
Purple is the best?
Yeah.
Oh, wait, no, I got guiding song Miku, though.
That's the one.
That's one of the comments.
Yeah, but purple is the best, though.
What do you even mean?
There's no purple.
Purple is the best.
Yes, because you haven't got it yet.
You haven't got purple.
How many stars is purple?
Purple is purple.
It's four.
Oh, why did I think it was green?
Are you sure you're not colorblind?
What color is Miku?
Okay, no, no, no, no, no.
because my chat was saying how purple was the best i thought
gold was the best and they're like gold's not even compared
to purple it was green when she held it oh my god yes i got
the i got the looking at the stars one that's the one i
wanted okay look i'll i'll it's like we're like the parent
trap you know parent trap we're like the parent trap we're
like the divorce what do you mean we're like the parent trap
what does that mean what does that mean the worst kids get
to be reunited chat gets it.
You're like, it's this cute.
What does, what does freaky Friday have to do with Peritrap?
What does the Peritrap have to do with Metony Mekin?
Oh my God.
Okay.
Wait, do I, can I kick your butt with just one pool or
should I?
Yes.
No, no, it's fine.
Let's let's do it.
Cool.
Okay.
I'm gonna tell you numbers you I enter them really really
fast before chat enters them Are you reading them out loud
to me?
Okay.
Yes, I'm gonna you go to okay You go to the oh a co-op show
yet your show co-op show and you enter via ID and yeah Wait
wait, I queued up.
I prevail.
Why did you queue up?
Back up back up back up back up how I leave back up There's
an error.
There's an error.
You know, oh, I can't leave either I was gonna do an
example, but that can't leave I.
I also got it I I'm doing the shrimp song.
I'm going to kick my butt.
I was also trying to show you how to do it.
And then I also got locked in.
I also got locked into it.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
It's all right.
I'm in a room with Moon, Duckie, Riru, and L.S.
It's a rarity.
I got my little pony fans in here.
let's go oh no no okay these guys this is gonna be like
warm-up so i can take down doki i needed this i needed what
difficulty are you doing doing it on yeah we gotta do the
same difficulty i was so scared i didn't pick anything i
don't know what's happening wait i don't even know how to oh
all right oh i think this is baby difficulty i i looked away
i was looking at my other monitor and then it started
It's not too bad.
Am I winning?
It's not too bad where I'm at.
Try to be too quiet.
Can you hear the song?
Oh, am I distracting you when you're clicking?
I'm singing my song to you?
Oh my god, I'm missing now.
Wait, I'm so locked in right now.
I think he's gonna become in a recession really easily.
You start seeing the song made me do worse.
I like create a different rhythm.
I
kind of think I'm winning.
Wait, there's like life.
I can kill the other people.
God.
Ah, no, I'm dead!
I live longer than I expected.
What?
You can die?
Yeah, you can't.
I thought the health was, like, a joke.
Did they kill you?
Can they use, like, like, power-ups to, like, put you down
or something?
Or did you just fail because you can't, you don't have any
skill?
Like, you can still keep playing, but then you don't
contribute, because it's, like, a co-op.
So, you're working, you're not actually- I think I'm just,
like, versus, or something.
I'm not down, co-op.
only have the only have co-op unless i'm wrong i could be
wrong who am i co-opping with who's my team the people
that's in your group what do you mean i thought i was versus
them i thought it was we were out to kill each other oh
there is rank oh is it only rank 1v1 what we have to play
rank no no i meant like can we make it so that we just
challenge each other think so it said we could do co-op yeah
but co-op is us working together and that's not fun was it
challenge show no oh it is rank match at the complete clear
at least five songs with full combo and yeah that's not
happening all right all right i'm gonna we can't play each
other no we can't all right are you outside of it um are you
out are you did you are you done crying yeah yeah i'm okay
okay okay you see enter via id you see that at the home
lobby or back to the show so you click on co-op show and
then the right side there's a enter via id i'm gonna say the
number is really really fast and you better type it why did
it queue up queue me up like why did it do that i didn't
click like i don't know if i click co-op is it just gonna
throw me into or something?
Go to co-op and do enter via ID, just click that.
Okay, okay, okay, you got it?
Yeah.
All right, and we'll see the numbers really, really fast and
y'all get in.
Okay, all right, I'm locked in.
Chat, you guys have stream delay.
All right.
No chance.
Okay, okay, are you ready?
Yeah, yeah.
All right, all right.
Yeah, here we go.
Four, two, three, four, six.
Yes, yes, you did it!
Hi, she's in.
Do it inside me hard?
What's this?
You can't have that as your name.
It has to be a new colorful stage.
Oh, my God.
We're in.
Who invited this guy?
It could be your chat.
It could be Monique.
We're shared.
We don't know.
Oh, my God.
I didn't know chat to join.
That's awesome.
Wait, no, I wasn't done picking my song.
Guys, what is that?
I'm done.
My song.
I want to do shrimp.
Shrimp is fun.
Dude, I'm gonna do hard mode.
Oh, you're gonna do hard mode.
Oh, you're gonna do hard.
All right, all right.
All right, we're both on hard.
How did she get past the filter for that name?
I know.
Hey, you guys want to play with us.
Remember to click on the link pinned in our chat.
Use the exclamation point Miku or scan our QR code.
You can play with us right now.
Download the game.
Oh my god, it started!
It started!
Wait, I don't have...
I only have one finger.
I only have one.
Roll another one.
I'm just a raccoon.
I only have one.
I'm pretty sure raccoons have opposable thumbs.
No, they don't!
That's an opossum, actually.
I'm not a marshy.
Raccoons can open doors.
Yeah, because we have body girth.
Haha!
Oh!
I'm using my virtual iPad right now.
Oh, crud.
There's more than one finger.
Let's grow another one.
I'm not going to live.
I'm not going to make it.
I'm going to be the first.
Wait, you died.
When did you die?
What's even the point anymore?
Well, we know that this is so much more complicated than the
easy setting.
Oh, we know who's Jimithy here.
I'm going to come back to life.
Please, Stokey, you have to win.
You can't let that guy win.
You can't let do it to me win.
I think he's winning.
I know he's going to win.
Somebody with a name like that is going to win.
I just know it.
That person means business.
He's already winning, too.
Stephanie, I don't think you realize this is a team game.
Because you're not a team.
You're like in the group project.
Where's my res?
You're like the guy in the team project that just shows up
at the presentation day.
I absolutely tap out of the game.
You like just show up on presentation day and be like, you
guys ready for my a's it's not my fault that i only have one
finger i mean it's sort of is though no no it's it's it's
all in meeku's plan dude it's meeku's plan you see if you
didn't die we I got us rigged.
That's all.
No!
We were so close.
Chad didn't carry me hard enough.
Only real Miku fans join up next lobby.
That's right.
You guys didn't care.
Wow.
All right, we'll do another one.
We'll do another one.
Are you ready?
Wait, wait.
Yeah, enter it really, really fast.
They have stream delay though.
They have stream delay, so it'll be possible.
Oh, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
All right.
You ready?
Yeah, re-download.
Okay.
I'm gonna give you the numbers really really fast and you
gotta be able to press it.
I'm ready, coach.
Okay.
I'm ready.
All right.
I got the dials.
The numbers on the dial.
Two six six four four.
Oh, second.
Yeah, I'm in.
Doki fan parentheses real.
Well, I hope this person, Gary.
All right.
I'm doing lock.
Let's try to meet you again.
Oh, oh, oh, yeah I got shrimp Miku and locked in I saw a
song that I really wanted to do before I don't even know
Where'd it go?
Okay, my mouth is open You can only hear it on Stuffy's
stream No!
Yeah, because I muted my own stream
Alright I'm gonna do normal because I'm not a gamer too hard
that way we can get s why are you laughing why are you you
don't think we can what hello where's your face well i'm
gonna make sure i'm gonna check out check it out on the top
left screen to see if you're alive okay i'm gonna fight for
my life all right here we go
no did you already
finger only somebody queue up a song where we can only have
one finger i can see when you miss a combo by the way okay
yeah and this my comp how does that have 140 there's not
even that many notes because you're adorable this guy has a
hundred notes playing right now 200 notes already what the
what the what the how do you even how do you even touch that
many times
have you never seen people play this game Stuffy?
No, no.
Oh, no.
I'm afraid of rhythm games.
I'm just a wannabe.
You're a larper.
I'm a larper.
No, these guys go hard.
It's like they have like 20 fingers when they're playing.
Are they playing with their toes?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Some people actually do that as a challenge.
They play with their toes.
No, I'm not.
Okay, are we gonna do that then?
You have your iPad.
Stuffy, first off, you gotta survive horror mode before you
think of that.
Well, I can't!
There's more than one finger!
I don't know what to do.
I'm dead.
No way you are!
You don't!
You're just God!
No!
And after all this time, Chad, I practiced so hard the other
day on my Wii.
Like rhythm games.
Oh,
I dropped my combo.
You know, this is pretty good for a first attempt on this
side.
Spits up blood.
I'm being good.
Oh no no no!
It's okay, I died.
But I died at the end.
Oh wait, someone else died too.
Not just us!
it's not just us that guy has a 890 combo and he has a kaito
avatar how do you lose a combo on the
end thanks for the carry kaito fan it's okay it's okay it's
because they didn't carry us hard enough it's not us wait
how do i choose my character i pulled and i didn't even get
to equip oh wait okay so i can send a message i'll send your
friend requests send me a message
Oh wait.
There, I sent you a friend request.
I sent my friend request.
Where?
I don't know, I've never done it before.
Make some friends.
No friends.
Oh, it's whole...
Oh yeah, it's...
I had a paid Doki fan.
added paid dokey fat and not dokeybird they paid for it okay
okay i added you did you read my message is this something i
can read out loud for the class yeah i read the messages up
here yeah did you read my message i spent like two minutes
writing it to you i spent two minutes writing it and you
didn't even read it you hate me wow this is why this is why
i closed my share chat this is exactly why i left i left the
collab room wow wait add me back as a friend i deleted you
so you can send me another wait he changed his name to
unpaid snuffy fan now
Because I denied him my friend.
Look, I denied him the friend request.
Oh, his allegiances have changed.
Wow.
You know what?
Yes.
Because you did that, I'll add you.
Reject.
Rejected live on stream.
See this?
Bam!
Goodbye.
That's right.
That's so sick.
Bye.
He did this for me.
He was just, he was just executed live.
I executed him.
Off with his head.
All right.
How do I change my...
All right, you want to change your team?
You go to characters and you go to edit.
Oh, wait.
Do I not have them or something?
You're like, what would they be under?
Character, characters and edit at the bottom.
Okay, I just changed, I just clicked recommended.
I don't know where they were hiding.
Okay, I have now a good team.
All right, you ready?
I'm gonna give you the ID.
Enter via, we'll do the shrimp.
We will eventually do the shrimp song.
All right, enter via ID.
I'm ready, I'm ready to enter.
All right, 07251.
07251.
Oh!
I got you.
All right, here you go.
Got my shrimp song this time.
Don't choose a song.
So we can play the strip song.
I like this one.
Don't choose a song.
I chose this one.
Oh my.
It better win.
Yeah!
Yay!
I hope you die in Hatsune Miku colorful stage.
Are threads allowed?
That wasn't the contract.
I said in game!
Hashtag in game.
Dude, this one looks good.
It looks like me.
It looks like my stream overlay chat.
I'm gonna win.
Jack Fonset.
You died like three times.
Oh my god, it has a music video.
Oh, this one's hard.
Oh.
But um, but um, but um.
Well, you're still alive.
Are you on easy?
No.
Right?
No, they just haven't needed me to press more than one
finger.
And that's totally because it's not easy.
It's just not wise for the song.
The beat doesn't match.
You know, it's just, I'm just really skilled at this one.
I've been practicing.
I can tell.
No, no, no, no.
Oh my God, oh my God.
Oh my God.
Oh,
oh.
Oh, all right.
What difficulty were you on?
What difficulty?
Eat your words.
Dang, we didn't even get an A though.
What the heck?
Oh, this guy was a superstar.
All right, I'll send you another friend of course.
All right.
Okay, write your piece with me.
I did This was a bit shorter Because I didn't want to spend
two minutes on it this time And you'll never know what that
two minute message was Not until I look at the clips You're
literally, you're Texas Kaito fan What's wrong with you?
It's called Irony It's called Irony Look it up, it's a
literary device stuffy it's i think that's called lying and
uh providing false information um it's ironic bro it's okay
we can have the same interests one more one more one more
and then i'm i'm leaving you into the wild and i'm playing
power wait guys is me and mince still on power world i don't
know they are if now see you got yeah they were playing for
a while i dropped in for like an hour oh they are all right
i'll see you and pal world later snuffy after this what if i
log in and everybody logged off and then i start crying huh
what what happens then that's better like for me oh my god i
can choke you right now in natsunemiku colorful stage yeah
i'm gonna choke you in natsunemiku colorful stage if you
guys also want to get choked make sure to dial up
Okay, are you ready for the ID?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, ready?
I'm going to give you a countdown.
Okay.
Okay, no countdown, joking.
No countdown because I'll think this is the numbers.
All right, 30220.
Oh, my God, you're in.
He's denounced both of us.
All right, wait, what?
Where?
Okay, how do I un...
I just don't...
Oh, my God.
Is that what you mean?
Yeah, yeah, you just don't click anything.
Okay.
What is this?
Gave about again.
It's about Hatsune Miku colorful stage All right, we got
shrimp we finally end on shrimp Miku
Let's go This song is so cute It is that's why I wanted to
do shrimp Miku
I hope it has a music video.
I don't know if it does.
I just know there's shrimp Miku.
I did not know that.
It's Miku, but like as a shrimp, I would buy a figure of
shrimp Miku.
Just like this?
In the background?
Yeah.
I would too.
I mean, it's really a...
And they'll make shellfish Kaito.
Shut this fuck up.
crustacean kaito guys this is why you have no friends on
Hatsune Miku Colorful Stage actually I have one friend on
Hatsune Miku Colorful Stage that's a pity friend only
because I didn't accept this friendly boy class oh my god
I'll take your pity friends one is a crowd
why do you think she's so mean to me is it because i'm it's
called tough love me too it's constant i'm trying to make
sure you're prepared for the real world i was already broken
by it today and i show up to work and then everybody bats
and tells me i have no friends Just another day in my
fucking chun, snuffy life, dude.
Oh, no, now I'm dead.
Now I'm dead, guys.
Don't you just made me lag.
Where have you got us, Rick?
Let's go.
Oh, man.
That was my worst performance yet.
I'm the best in the world.
A generational Asian toxic trauma from don't eat a snuffy.
Oh, my God.
We actually got an S on that one though.
Wait, wait, you should try the hardest difficulty and just
see how funny.
Just, just, just.
I'll just instantly lose.
No, just see the difference.
Just see, okay, I'll do one last one with you just to see
the difference.
Oh my God.
All right.
Okay.
Are you ready?
Okay, yeah.
All right, you got the enter via ID?
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, all right.
09707.
Woo.
Whoa, got in, you got in.
All right, all right, two people got in.
Choose the hardest song for us.
Choose the hardest song.
The hardest song.
And then we'll do the hardest game mode.
All right, it's Tripp Me Too.
All right, I'm gonna do it faster.
a master
this guy's name just destroyed my booty why do i feel like
this has got to be the same guy as before all right watch
this watch this this is how they got 100 notes by the way
snuff you're gonna see where the 100 notes came from i'm
scared i don't even know how to process
My combo of one, my powerful combo, I'm dead.
I died, I died in soo.
You see where the 100 don't...
How do you even...
Look at...
Your eyes have to cross.
What are you...
How do you...
What?
Oh my god, oh my god.
I can just start clicking and it'll work out.
Oh my god.
it starts curving what what is going on what is it like
sliding across the screen like a ballerina it's me too on
ice me too on ice oh my god i hit my the magnificent combo
of seven
oh my god
Eventually I'll hit something.
Is Mika gonna like take me out back for this performance?
You're gonna get old Yellard?
I'm gonna get fired.
Yeah!
I don't qualify to be on the colorful stage.
You're like the backup, backup, backup, backup, backup.
I don't think I've gotten a combo higher than two.
I got ten somehow.
I kind of expected you to be cracked at it.
I don't know why
Oh my word did it did we get an S guys did we guys did we
get an S we gotta be Other players has been detected you
just get I think I got reported You got reported I got
reported for inappropriate conduct What did you do?
Why?
My rank has been adjusted I was, they thought I was trolling
because I was so bad?
What?
Joey, they think you were throwing.
It was a game with friends.
Why?
Why didn't you make it?
They thought you were throwing.
Crazy.
You're on kick from being bad at a video game.
I never expect that.
Oh my god, I knew, I told you guys Viku was taking me out
back.
That's actually, that's actually crazy.
I think you sabotaged me.
You told me to throw a master.
I didn't, I didn't, I didn't get reported.
This typical don't, you always sabotaging me.
Hey guys, you want to follow and support a streamer that
didn't get reported for throwing in hot soda and me?
Colorful Sage, feel free to click on the link pinned in my
chat or Exclamation for Miku or on the QR code and to
support the stream this channel and this sponsor
You're gonna support a person that that throws the game I
need the pity just like Doki said the pity click yeah yeah
yeah come on guys it woes me only got one finger
please i follow snuffy because she runs it down mid i if
there was a way to do that in a rhythm game i just found out
she ran it down mid in the rhythm game that's crazy i didn't
realize you can even get I didn't even realize that was
possible.
I hope that doesn't, like, affect my sponsor in any way.
That's funny, though.
Yeah, she was trying her best, guys.
She was trying her best, guys.
She was trying.
Also, if you click on the link in the top right, you'll see
a web store, and there's a 20% off on Crystal Bonuses for
your first purchase right now.
So make sure to check that out, guys.
And remember, I'm piecing out now.
but I think stuff you're gonna keep going right uh yeah yeah
yeah I'm not ending the stream but I'm gonna go play power
world now but I good luck with the rest of Hatsune Miku
colorful stage thank you Doki good luck and have fun gotcha
the rest of your characters okay thanks bye all right have
fun bye now see you in power world okay all right guys
Alright, we're gonna swap.
But yeah, thank you again to Hatsune Miku, Colorful Stage,
for the sponsor for today's stream.
I'm glad we were able to, I streamed a little bit longer for
today, just because, like, you know, Suffy was having
technical difficulties for the, but we're still gonna keep
going, but I did stream a little longer for the, for the
sponsor, just because, like, just because, like, we were
supposed to collab anyway, so I figured I'll just, I'll just
hang out a little bit longer just to play, play with Suffy.
It was fun.
Anyway, we're going to go on Palworld now.
But yeah, to support the stream, to support the stream, the
channel, and the sponsor.
It really helps a lot.
If you click on the link and try out the game yourself, this
game has a lot of free stuff, too.
So there's a lot of stuff to do in Hasimiku, Colorful Sage.
But yeah, thank you again.
All right, let me boop.
still locked up in the basement are you still there because
I forgot what the sound balancing was for this game so I'm
gonna need some help guys I already forgot what it was
whoops that's my game unplugged it there you go all right
are you still in that oh they are they are get back in there
back to work i could wait wait wait wait where's the other
microphone let me see where i put it guys i do have the
other microphone but it's gonna i'll do it tomorrow i'll do
the other microphone tomorrow i'll fix that tomorrow all
right we're gonna boot up pal world uh boop uh let's see
let's see let me double check everything let me make sure we
got everything oh yeah you guys are still are you guys still
hanging out with snuffy oh wait she ended it okay never mind
we're back we're back home she left the home all right let's
see let's see back to palling it up with the
I don't know how quiet I was on this stream but I will have
another microphone to try out for tomorrow oh does she just
leave oh that's funny well we're gonna speed run a little
we'll play a little bit just so it's enough we can join and
then I'll leave when she joins so I can keep the keep the
bit going just so so I can keep the bit they're not all
right give me a sec
all right
let's see what's going on keep the cycle going
all right what's going on on your repair my stuff anyway.
I'm gonna go back.
I don't want to be in this area.
This area is too depressing.
Honestly, we're...
This area is way...
This area is too depressing.
I'm gonna leave this area.
I'm gonna go back to the palace where everybody's happy and
enjoying life.
I like it here more.
People are happier.
Let me repair my bow.
Okay, repair.
Fuck it, we're so rich right now.
Alright, well, can I upgrade anyway?
Let's saddle.
Let me cleaver.
We'll grab this.
There's really nothing I really need to make right now
because they all made everything.
At best, I'll need a crossbow.
I'll need a bit of a bow.
Alright, let's go level up real fast.
I also can just make orbs because I'm just going to be like,
goink.
Alright, let's go.
see um how many can't make technically whoa we have wait oh
my god they've been farming i will do speed run now you what
i mean like i didn't make them depressed yeah they have a
lot of power okay we're just gonna speed run level up
honestly the only way to do is just by caching pals
Actually All right, how many do I need?
I need How many do I need it should tell me what you're
still alive?
Oh shit.
Well, he was still alive Usually okay, I have one out of
five.
Okay, the best way to level It's just catching paths
All right, let's grab as many as we can Okay, I know I have
one of you Get over here All right Yay kidnapping I don't
get a lot of power only because this is like my fifth time
on a power world server and it's like the grind the grind
takes so long too you know
Yeah So I have the dragon okay before the dragon server
before the sloppy server I Had I you know I tried I went to
the the Sakura area So I had that and then I had the my
server that I did spend like the most time on Um, the server
that I spent the most time on that's not that I can't access
it anymore So it's like Okay, my speed running I'm doing
like ultra speed run.
Okay, I just need one more of the landfill And then get over
here Yeah But like to get to the part where I haven't
experienced the game yet takes so long That's the worst part
So like I know like that's all the tech on like what oh I
don't have whatever I don't have like all the I like sorry,
I know all the tech on a lot of stuff, but it takes so long
to get there so it's like You have to grind the stuff again
that's why i haven't been on the pal like i've only been on
this is like the first time i've been on the pal world
server it's a more fun when you're with uh when you're with
friends and stuff for sure but even then i'm just hanging
out and chatting you know i'm just like not really like
actually sort of like playing the game i'm just like fucking
around and hanging out with everybody which is fun that's
like the best part about uh i think this is the best part of
like these types of servers is that you're just hanging out
yeah i know some of the speed run strats and stuff uh but
i'm not i'm just doing like my current i'm just i'm just
trying to speed run leveling up and i think the easiest way
the easiest way to speed run leveling up is exploring and
exploring everything and catching pals i find i don't
remember but it might be
surprised if it's different now on like how to okay who
constructs you is it still is the capturing still the
fastest way to level up I don't remember because I want my
guns you know it's the same is it still like capturing pals
to run okay I'll just do that I just want my guns you know I
want everybody to log in and just see me with the guns and
just be like hey guys i'd be like pew pew i'd just be like
in the industrial era while everyone's still in the stone
age i just want to flex the pistols oh my god you do the
work i'll make some palace palace spheres too since we have
so many i'm only at default but it's fine i'm fine with what
do I have I might as well enhance some all enhance the work
speed just for this yeah I'm trying to I'm playing Sib right
now I'm trying to speed run technology victory right now
only have bow also I'm so sorry about I haven't been able to
read uh all the uh subs and uh all the and the um twitch
prime and everything i'm so sorry guys i'm like like i said
i'm not really fully i guess like all right what's fine come
back here not really like not really on my actual setup
right now uh so that's why like uh stuff is a little bit
scup i hope it's still entertaining I hope everyone is still
entertained Even if it's very scum.
No!
Oh my god, my entire team's killer Oh my I was not expecting
my entire team to fuck him up Yeah, he got nuked I Actually,
no, I don't need these guys are like babies.
I can just Okay, I don't remember how many I need from these
guys All right That one okay, I got all the chickens.
I don't need to worry about the chickens All right, I know I
need the cats
I need two of these guys Okay, I already completed a cat
Whoops, bonus cat.
Yeah, I'm really close, I think.
Bonus cat.
Yeah, these guys are babies, that's what I've been doing.
I'm just shooting the babies.
What happened?
Yeah, I just need one more.
Alright, goodbye.
That's why I killed your father.
You're lucky I won't kill you too, because I already have
five of you.
Oh, I don't need you.
that's right oh i touch this i i did the sea lion um i
couldn't do the dolphins because that was fully booked but
honestly i think the sea lion experience was is so much i'll
talk about i'll talk about it again um on a youtube stream
or like back home um because you know talking about it on
Twitch is pretty scuffed right now no it was honestly so
cool because uh no okay I it they are they're actually
they're like oh they're like the dogs of the sea and they
actually are they're like they look like dad they actually
look just like him like the way their expressions and
and they gave me a hug they gave me um a visioner has
arrived who cares they I they do like know like these tricks
where they uh they gave me like a hug and a kiss and it's so
cute but then we were not allowed to bring our phones um in
the water and everything because like you know it's still
like it's like a what's it called it was still like a um
what's it called rehabilitation center uh for But they
obviously need to make money and stuff So like for them to
make money is so that they have like They make it so that
you can't take any photos So there was a cameraman there to
take photos for you and they get to pay for the photos And
so I paid for the photos I thought it was just so cute like
they actually hug you and give you kisses And I'm like Oh Oh
It's cute because the money goes towards the sea lion like
rehabilitations like rescues and stuff so like if that's
fine you know if the money is going towards the sea lions
I'm fine with that you know like if it goes towards
funding funding towards them it's fine with me whoops yeah
and honestly I think it's better like the thing is I've
never done anything with dolphins before even though they're
like the they're the sexual harassers of the sea like that's
me putting it by the way that's a nice way of seeing it but
it would be like Doki that's a nice way of saying what they
are but it's like you know whenever you go to like you know
do like those types of vacation you would normally the first
thing is the dolphin but it was fully booked by honestly
think i honestly think the uh the the the sea lion
experience is 100 better than the dolphin experience because
you can't really like the dolphins just like do i guess like
do tricks and stuff but i don't think it's the same as um oh
my god why are you
oh shit i'm just gonna throw that for now just so he would
stop running i'm gonna fucking catch you just there we go
just you thought you could run away i have so many pal bugs
i will keep chucking until you're inside it yeah they're
actually a water they are they're so cute and i just think
it's so cute when start like uh we weren't even fighting i i
just got a rat just randomly catch them like yeah food and
i'm like yeah pal yeah they're like guys we're dying today
and i'm like guys i have some pals tonight
They're so cute.
But yeah, like, because, like, the dolphins, you can't
really do much with the dolphins.
I guess you can swim with them or something.
I mean, like, I guess, like, yeah, but I felt like the sea
lion experience just seems like a much better experience in
general.
Alright.
I just need...
You know what?
Fuck it.
You go kill him.
Might be faster.
I got bored.
You go hit him That actually might be faster Alright Do I
have all of it?
Okay, I'm not caught a cow.
I thought I got a cow before But I haven't caught him Oh, I
caught him in the drag I lost track I've lost track which
I've caught And wish I haven't caught Oh, and they're so
fast though They're actually They're so fucking fast Yeah,
I don't I need to know how many how many I have left How
many do I have you left?
Oh nice I'm a level 14 now Alright nice I told you I already
have them I legitimately forgot I guess it tells you when it
doesn't show it anymore Because that's how The yellow orb
means you have 5 How do I know when it's yellow Oh, it has
the gold icon.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I don't have it.
Whoops.
Alright, kill him.
I am speedrunning right now.
It's like the quickest way to level up.
And towers, but like, uh.
I'll just do this.
Next to it.
Oh, next to their names.
Oh, I see.
I just didn't remember.
used to be really fast too because like am I full no why
can't I give me my oh my inventory oh I am full whoops just
put that in here okay there you go whoops all right we're
grabbed how do I ping dad to heat him up how do I ping my
pals again guys i don't remember it's not working oh shit he
killed him i can't ping did i unbinded accident i must have
unbinded it or some shit i must have been like fuck that
shit let's see common where is it keyboard where is it
controller pad Where's the
Aim middle click Where is it at?
Oh is it on controller pad?
No that's aim On the left control Oh left section menu Oh
there it is Where is it Throw pal move change command Oh
wait, it is.
Why did it not work?
Huh?
Why won't you do my...
Hey, hey, why aren't you?
Oh, I have to aim and click.
Okay, just kill him.
I don't care, honestly.
Just kill this guy.
Kill for him for my amusement.
All right.
I need you in my collection you're just here to look pretty
in my pal box that's right that's your only purpose you have
no other purpose to serve okay I don't have all of him you
live to speed run my collection so I could speed run my tech
my tech tree that's your only purpose oh shit you're still
alive yeah I never stopped big day I have all the penguins
okay I need to give me XP me hungry I legit I think I can,
like, I can, like, uh, get to level 20, I think, with the
rate I'm going.
I think I get to level 20 easily.
Maybe even more than that.
Did he escape that?
That cheeky little bastard.
Alright, get over here.
Get over here.
I don't even need to get it all the way to the end.
Get him, too.
All right, get this guy as well.
Oh, nice.
Okay, I'm level 15.
Do I have these birds?
Yeah, I do.
All right.
Let's do stamina.
Work speed.
Wait.
Okay, what can I get in the technology tree?
Okay, we gotta get that.
We gotta get the crossbow.
Okay, average.
feed uh okay we gotta get the mega shield all right get over
here whoops oh fuck okay nope get over here oh whoop get
over i keep thinking it's ee to like ride keep getting
confused all right where am i let's see i'm so far from
anything they already have all of you have all of you let's
go to the other side I need to get some more spawn points oh
yeah get him get him I don't have you yet get in my
collection yeah
get him my collection your only purpose is to be in my pal
box oh shit oh shit my weapons damage that's not good
actually all right now i can catch him um he'll live
actually no i don't want to it's all right we'll get mad in
here that's right shoot him oh shit don't wait not okay you
might have shot him a bit too guys who would have thought
bullets hurt but but wait not like that though that was a
little too strong no one ever expects man with guns see this
is what I'm trying to see This is exactly why I need a speed
run speed run to gun This is exactly why Little 15 yep.
I'll stop at level 20
You don't see Okay
Well, you get gun you see you can have like weak ass guns,
but like I need like stronger gun I can't have these
push-ups sea guns.
Okay, we want to unlock the grappling gun.
I should have got that first.
Have I not encountered the bird upgrades yet?
Okay, I think I should be able to make bird saddles now,
right?
What level is the flying mounts?
I don't remember the flying mount.
Is level 20?
Okay.
Oh my god, I keep thinking it's E!
Everything else is E!
Alright.
Let's just...
Oh, I need to use that anyway.
Alright, we're gonna send man out.
He has a gun.
I need to repair this too.
Alright, shoot him.
Just shoot him.
Alright.
There we go.
Oh.
Alright, nice.
Alright, shoot him.
Let's go.
Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Clearly it works.
Alright, you come back now.
Alright, man.
Man, man.
Come back.
Man!
Man doesn't want to come back!
Man, come!
He's so...
He's a free man's like I'm not coming back into this ball
Man wants to shoot gun man get back in here
He's like freedom And we need to repair we gotta get our
bone out You don't have to write badges to command man.
He's a free man now Dobby's a free man okay well I can
technically make the crossbow now I'll make it this stuff oh
wait I do have fly mount okay night wings I don't remember
where the night wings are um oh nice I got all the arrows
okay where's can I make the crossbow okay I don't need this
anymore Oh, kind of need ingots.
Uh, oh my gosh, I need so many ingots.
What the fuck?
We have too many of these benches!
Okay.
Oh my god, it's all ingots.
Where are our ingots?
Oh, wait, never mind.
We have a lot of them.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, wait, we do have a crossbow.
What the fuck?
Oh, wait, I have an epic schematic for it, too.
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, let's put some stuff away.
Um, we'll put stuff in the...
Alright.
Oh, I need to put stuff away.
Let's see.
Quick stack.
Does that stack everything?
Yeah, that stacks everything.
Okay.
well let me grab I'm surprised nobody took these ingots out
well at least I can make stuff now I'll make the epic
crossbow oh god that took that takes way too long man surely
man is good at making ah that takes way too long man never
mind oh should have a makeshift hang okay let me make my
grappling gun yeah that is not moving everybody's sleeping
right now nobody's here to work man will make the crossbow
supposed to be speed running right now how am i supposed to
be speed running
oh my god where is my speed one eternity later uh work work
yeah but it's like it feels like a handgun that's gonna
explode on itself all right we're gonna leave when they when
we finish our fucking crossbow
I'm gonna try and get this grappling gun and then I'll see
now I guess I'll repair it then I love worthless shit in my
inventory but whatever I have a lot of money in my inventory
I don't even know where I got this money okay oh that's true
I can sleep till it's daytime I'll make the grappling gun
first and then I'll sleep and I'll have the other palace
make the crossbow and then I'll have like snuffy steal it or
some shit knowing her oh wait might as well
oh yeah I forgot to reduce the egg hatching time oopsie
I forgot to reduce the egg incubator time whoops well no
guess they'll have to wait 23 hours best to do i'll do it
later i'll do it later i don't think she knows about it i
don't think she knows that you can reduce the incubation
time it's not on her it's on me That the fuck I have a
grenade?
That's just a little oopsie.
I'll just repair this for now.
I'll repair this for now so I can catch more pals.
Alright.
Megasphere.
Yeah, she wouldn't know.
I usually, we did it like what?
Half the time?
Right?
it was like half the time or something i don't remember
oh i got sunburned oh yeah by the way for those who know i
got sunburned in um in the bahamas because i was so fucking
stupid i yeah i just like i just i don't know i i didn't
know the sun can go do a 360 guys i i have the alloy thing
yeah I had a sun 360 new I didn't know it was possible I was
like a guy I did it I covered my entire body with sunscreen
the entire front portion of my body I did it guys don't no
worries it was nice it was really beautiful I didn't really
like You know like the pictures of like the very like the
light blue ocean?
Like I didn't think that was real.
I thought that was CGI I didn't think ocean can get that
like pastel and that was crazy.
I thought the only thing you can get is like, you know, like
the chlorine from you know how like In a pool So the in
pools the reason why the water looks like that is because
like they paint the The pool Blue so it gets like in that
light blue Yeah, I've seen a I live in Canada.
I saw I've seen a lot of sad beaches guys like In Canada sad
beaches are very common People don't really swim in the
Canadian beaches
So I've never seen like an actual that's why I don't like
the beach slash ocean because all I've seen of the beaches
are very sad beaches I've never seen like actual beaches
beaches.
So like yeah, so like I didn't I wasn't scared of Oh, yeah,
by the way, apparently the Bahama beaches have jellyfish
because there was a giant ass sign that says Beware of
jellyfishes nah, and then like the kids were like, oh my god
Jellyfish, I was like silly kids.
There's no jellyfish here and I saw a giant ass sign I was
like beware of jellyfish and I was like, oh, oh no
now I'm paranoid oh wait we're almost done now I'm very
paranoid uh where is where the fuck is there okay there is I
just don't want it to sting me yeah I don't care I don't
care about like like I just don't want it to sting me I do
care a lot but it's just you know the fact that i don't like
pain i really don't like the pain i pain is bad
do we have more we have more dioros right oh that's a lot of
why are you chopping the tree oh my god Why is he chopping
the tree?
Oh, he's so dead Oh my god Fuck it shoot that guy
Oh shit, he killed the man Oh shit wait, I got cooler dad
though.
I got coolest dad.
No, it doesn't matter.
I can't I killed her.
I killed her leader.
Oh my god!
Where is he?
Where's my...
Where's the cooler man?
Man dead.
Yeah, man, man very dead.
Wait, is he actually dead?
No, he's fine.
I'm just gonna let him do his stuff.
Is that... Oh my cool.
What happened?
I was trying to capture Oh Bro exploded What the did he
throw a fucking grenade?
What did he do?
Oh shit, what the fuck?
What is this?
Some random birds this this spawn weirdly I mean I can grab
one more
oh fuck it put that berry in here got my dog coin oh that's
why there are so many wolves I was like what the fuck
happened here all right we're all the spawners we're all the
pals
Pals.
Oh, pal.
Oh, there's another man.
Can you get five of man?
Gun versus gun.
1v1.
Third party.
I'm third partying.
Who would win?
Cooler man or man?
The aura farmer.
Nah, he's fucking dead.
should point and blink just do that.
That's fine.
I should catch him.
I'm so confident too.
Wait, it doesn't give me more?
Aw.
I thought they would give me more.
Fine.
Shoot him.
All right, there you go.
Are you serious?
There you go.
Oh, love and mind, level 16.
We're almost there.
We're almost done the level 20 speed run.
Look at this guy.
No, not him.
What?
You got out?
Get back in here.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
No point.
That guy's dead.
Alright.
Where else can you catch some pals?
Yeah, I know.
I didn't really clean my inventory.
I'm too late.
I'm really bad at that.
And then he like...
crafting game or whatsoever like i just i i just stuff
everything into a locker and call it a day whatever i do
like i don't care i just i all i need food okay food and and
ammo i don't care what's in my inventory i people hate me
every time i play like these like Like, doesn't matter,
Minecraft, Terraria, Powell World.
Any type of thing where requires me to gather loot, I will
absolutely not sort my item.
Someone, cause the thing is, someone else can do it for me.
It's not me.
And that's not me.
I'm not that someone.
Oh, I just put everything in the box and be like, you sort
it.
That's how I do it.
I put everything in a box, you sort it.
I hate those players.
That's me.
Alright, nice.
To have all that, nope.
Alright, slap him.
Oh my god, not like that.
He's like, you said slap him.
Oh my god.
Holy shit, he touched that guy.
Oh, nice, there are a couple.
I'm gonna kill him.
I'm gonna shoot him.
Are they like together?
Oh, they are.
Oh, they come like in a pack.
I've never seen, oh, these ones are These are in you.
These guys are in you.
I've never seen them before Oh, you can't even separate them
even if you want to it would be funny if I could kill one
and leave the other alive Toki what do you mean by funny?
It'd be pretty funny
Toki why
Oh And that's got it.
All right, how many more do I need?
Oh, I need all of them.
All right.
Just to see how they react, you know?
I'm just a curious little guy.
What's- what's interesting is that in PAL world, they don't
evolve at all.
Whoops.
I thought that's interesting like obviously there's
something that look like I guess you don't want to get
double sued by Nintendo which makes sense like They don't
want to give Nintendo more ammo I guess They're already sort
of like Yeah, I think that like maybe draws the line they're
worried like it gives them too much ammo But did you money
well?
Yeah, but then like they're already like in the crosshairs
of Of Pokemon so they don't want to get into more trouble I
guess They're just worried All right kill this one guy
I guess they're just worried that it'll cause more issues
what the fuck okay like it Surprises me every time like I
can't take you anywhere.
I She can't take you anywhere.
I fool you just keep fucking blasting
Don't worry.
I'll be fine.
Tis just a scratch I was sabotaging my levels.
I swear to God Yeah, his burst damage is so fucking high.
Like, what the fuck?
Yeah, it started fucking blasting.
Alright, he should be done with...
Why is nobody doing this?
He's so confused.
Waiting to refine?
What do you mean, waiting to refine?
It's right there.
My man is so confused.
He doesn't know how to refine.
Okay, now I can grab that.
All right, I'll put this away.
All right, nice.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I need those arrows.
Oh, what?
Oh, never mind.
Grab.
Put that back in here.
Creamer Palisperes.
Oh, he was told to use that furnace.
Okay, that makes more sense.
I was going to say, like, Bro!
Where's the ingots?
Oh, I put the ingots away somewhere.
Put the extra ingots somewhere.
Alright, well I gotta...
Just...
Go.
I gotta throw you.
How do I...
I gotta throw...
Okay.
Go.
Fire.
Use fire.
Fire good.
are you using fire are you oh he was hungry okay that's
that's fine that's fine just go eat your thing where did i
put the ingots i thought i had more they already make oh
they already used the bomb of the ingots earlier i thought i
had more ingots they're stash them oh i used them all up
Okay, whatever.
I still have some left.
Oh, I'll just make these then.
I'm going to make the tiny ones for now.
I didn't even realize I used it all up.
Okay.
Yeah, you can fly them.
I'm going to...
Let's see.
I'm going to do this.
I'm going to...
Where's the big dad that I caught earlier?
Pal management sort by Sort by that right sort by There you
All right, and then we're gonna make you We're gonna make
you This dad
Ace, thank you for the raid, thank you, thank you, we had a
great stream today, I'm playing Palo World right now,
alright, we're gonna get that and then, sorry, cooler man, I
think, I'm pretty sure, yeah, I'm pretty sure man is
stronger than coolest man, alright, we're gonna have to grab
this and then make, fly, we're gonna fly today.
Oh, God, okay.
Man.
Craft.
Mining craft.
Oh, this is too long.
Get out of here.
We'll let them do the work.
This takes too long.
Oh, wait.
I can grab.
Grab four.
And then...
that my unpaid laborers go do the thing do what you were
bred to do without for exposure hey they chose to be caught
by me it was a choice what the fuck is that I've never seen
these guys before these little guys man oh that's a lot of
them oh this reload takes fucking forever though oh holy
shit spawn again that's crazy okay a little bit more more
than I expect.
That's it.
I'm sending in the nuke.
Nuke them!
Oh my god, it's hot.
I have to nuke them.
I have to send in the nuke.
Which one's the boss?
I can't tell!
Okay, it's fine.
I'm dodging them all.
Alright, there we go.
Oh shit, he nuked himself.
Alright.
Alright, I got the giant chickens though.
They're almost like a nuke.
There we go.
It's time for some eggs.
Oh shit!
Oh,
there you go.
Alright, back in here.
Alright, yay, more eggs!
I received a meme mod effigy.
Yippee.
Oh, it, like, bugged out again.
Oh, fuck.
All right, there you go.
All right, nice.
All right.
Well, everyone's dying again.
That's okay.
You go catch more.
No, I still have a lot of inventory space.
Oh.
Should be able to catch some pals here.
I don't like the crossbow.
It takes 20 years to reload.
Have I seen these guys?
These guys are new.
Oh wait, I love these guys!
They're so cute.
Look at these guys.
Oh, they're so cute.
They remind me of this.
I remember I said it before, but they remind me of a Swablu.
I just don't like how long this takes.
All right, that's it, bite him.
Oh, my God!
Cooler dad was not meant to, coolest dad was not meant to
fight these guys.
All right, maybe...
Man, go back in there.
Shoot him.
Okay, all right, that's fine.
That's fine.
We didn't need...
We only needed one, I guess.
That's okay.
Level 18.
He showed up.
the wrong one you're I should have specified which one to
shoot I mean like it is a lot of damage it's just reload
time is a fucking bitch honestly not a fan of the reload
time oh shit he's already dead what did that happen I
I swear to God, if you shoot him the moment he's won!
Wait, where is he?
Aura farming.
Is Aura farming so far?
What?
Alright.
I definitely need the mega.
I can't be using the playing pal.
Oh my god, it's a party.
I can't be using the playing pal balls anymore.
This guy's just too ass.
I ain't catching shit with these.
I'm actually not catching jack shit with these.
They're so weak.
It's alright.
Matt's taking all the damage.
It's okay.
No!
I don't mind.
It's no longer okay.
It's no longer.
Okay, let me grab my stuff.
oh yeah the statue i forgot about the statues yeah pal i
made it i wanted to make it more exciting it's fine i think
it's more exciting i need to level up my capturing i forgot
about that shit i need to find more effigies then for it
i think it's more fun that way
oh i have it so that if i die i lose uh my pals i did i just
didn't think i get one shot yeah i lose
everything it's on deep because i didn't want to play like
weenie hut junior you know like we ain't no weenie hut
junior we ride or die
all right wait man died what the fuck did man die okay let
us uh well my mind okay my flying mount should be done now
i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure
yeah the sloppies ain't no weenie hut juniors that's right
uh oh nice okay we might have finished our stuff what did I
make in here where's my sad oh my god they gave up at like
the last moment okay nice all right uh might be able to use
this now okay let me put some eggs oh snuffy's about to join
watch this let me put pigs in here first
oh it's all messed up hold on hey snuffy is that you yeah
that's me
I told I gotta keep the bit going Is she still Is she just
talking to herself?
Is she just Is she actually just Talking to herself right
now?
I gotta keep the bit going Guys I get
Is she Is she still going?
Is she actually still talking to herself?
That's good.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, wait, I put the wrong password.
What do you mean?
She wanted me to keep the bit going, so I did.
I told you what I was gonna do I told you it was
foreshadowing and here you are back again though you you
didn't want to stay too far away you didn't have it and you
just
The worst shadow gets a linear device in what?
Hey, she pushed her as long.
The bit that keeps on.
Kidney.
Hey, it's my fault.
She, she, she kind of, yeah, she kind of, she kind of, she
kind of did walk into that one.
Guys, is it really my, she walked into it.
What was I supposed to do?
She offered herself the, the, the bit.
All right, but I should have to go.
I should have to go.
I'm sorry, stuffy.
I have to grab food and I have to fix my uh I actually have
to leave I said in the play until snuffy shows up and that
was my cue to end
I said that was my cue to end all right don't worry i'll
raid her
not even a goodbye all right watch watch i won't even log in
i'll just call her
i don't even she'll pick up i don't even i don't even creep
through my presence in foul world i just call her on discord
get ghosted hey hey if she ghosted me I'm calling it here
she's not even noticing it no I think she had hey hey
sweetheart miss me already no I gotta go for real oh yeah I
bet I bet yeah hey I'm gonna I'm just here to say goodbye.
I'm just here to say goodbye.
A kindness I did not expect, but I appreciate it.
Yeah, what were you doing?
What's your plans and powers?
I don't know.
I haven't played this game.
.
Okay, okay, okay.
Or it's this hard, like, oh, hey.
Oh, oh, oh, my God.
Why did you just realize I left the call?
I did, no, it's, I did.
I was just, you know, talking to my chat because I'm a
famous streamer.
Oh, you had live, you were talking for, I think like 20
seconds with me out of the call.
Yeah, yeah, because I don't have a hot key to mute.
You wish I was that talented.
I saw I saw your little face disappear off my screen and I
knew I knew this bird left me once again all right well I
actually gotta go snuffy okay I hope you have fun and power
thank you I'm sorry I was so late I missed out on hanging
out together no it's okay we did so we got some songs in We
got shrimp Miku.
Shrimp Miku.
Yeah, that was fun.
Thank you for doing that with me.
Of course.
Yeah, stay a little longer because I wanted to 1v1.
Thank you, though.
We appreciate it.
Of course.
I might hop in later off stream because I'm just, I didn't
fix my microphone.
Well, not my microphone.
The setup's microphone.
Yeah, yeah.
That's fair.
I might be on.
a little bit longer if you if you care you know yeah that's
so funny that okay yeah it's hilarious that's such a funny
joke she laughs at me in every regard no i don't i'm gonna
go eat dirt off the it's okay it's okay i just so you know
i'm not laughing with you you're not i'm not laughing with
you yeah just so you know What do...
So...
Can't you just go?
Don't you have some place to be?
Didn't you say you were busy or something?
Oh, all right.
It's tough love, Snuffy.
It's tough love.
I'm helping you through the real world.
This is why I have to roleplay being a grandpa.
You wouldn't treat your grandpa like this, right?
you sweet grandpa you would love him normal my grandpa my
grandma wasn't at home well i'm your grandpa i'm right here
love me please all right grandpa how do you feel about being
in the home you can put in a home wow it's for your own good
grandpa you can hurt yourself you know what if i'm not
Grandpappy So you're abandoning me once again No, it's just
you know how to make money You know To support the family
Grandpa can help Grandpa can help Take him to work with you
Grandpa you put your money under In the pillowcase
underneath your bed Oh my god I don't know if I can trust
grandpappy's financial advice this will be worth thousands
just wait we get into the debt because of you grandpappy oh
my god no no it wasn't me it was it was grandma she had a
gambling problem but it wasn't me i played i play colorful
stage colorful stage back then grandpappy was top five and a
and that's your name you should have seen grandpa's fingers
go that's why grandma kept me around that's what he's saying
grandpa's good with his fingers all right i've got donkeys
here to this day i gotta go for real though but could have
fun in pal world snuffy okay might drop by later after i fix
my audio stuff Okay, okay.
All right, bye-bye.
Boing, boing.
All right, that was fun.
That is one finger.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
Snuffy and her fucking one finger.
All right, that was fun, guys.
Have you guys had fun even, even?
Oh, now you guys are like telling me to stop talking.
You wanted me to talk to Snuffy more.
And be like, don't leave her hanging.
And now you tell me to stop.
make up your minds guys make up your fucking mind
do you or do you not want me to talk to her
anyway guys i will have to go now i'm gonna fix my audio
because i do have a my rivals tournament tomorrow i'm still
trying to decide what i want to do on twitch or youtube i
might i don't know guys i feel like every rivals tournament
there's something going on and I'm sort of getting tired of
being in the middle of it.
That's why I was like, maybe I should do it on Twitch.
Because if it's something goes on, at least it's on Twitch
instead of rivals.
Yeah, that's why I was just like, like something always
happens.
And I'm just like, do I really want to have another?
Yeah, so I'm just like, I feel like maybe I should just toss
it on Twitch and that's point like yeah and then anyway guys
I'll think about I think about it tonight whether it's gonna
be on Twitch or YouTube but as always everybody stay
hydrated posture check get up and we're around to get that
blood flowing so yeah for me head to bed cuz you deserve it
if you're new here I usually stream on YouTube I just got
back from vacation doesn't really it feels like it and also
doesn't feel like it at the same time but
but I usually am on YouTube and I legitimately just got back
from the Bahamas I'm not at home though I'm crashing at
someone set up if you guys want to check out the merch to
support me the other reason I might send the birthday merch
again because I feel like I didn't have a chance to actually
advertise the birthday merch I want to make sure every
dragon is able to have a chance to get it um so I'll be
talking about merch if I can have one I know one more week
extension just Because I haven't been advertising it just
because of how busy I've been.
I want to make sure every dragon has a chance to get it.
Maybe like, oh my gosh, why did I didn't know there was?
So I'll try to extend it one more week just in case.
And also, what else?
You want to follow me on Twitter?
That's when I tweet out whenever I'm streaming on Twitch.
You want somewhere to get other memes.
I have like gamer subcode and dokeymerch.com for merch.
I have a Fortnite code.
I have an Apex code.
It's all dokeybird.
All that's dokeybird.
What else?
And you can follow me on my socials and stuff.
But yeah, check out YouTube, main channel.
I'll see you guys later, everybody.
I'm gonna read Snuffy now.
Bye, guys.
Bye.